la séance est reprise
j'informe le Sénat que des candidatures
pour sierger au sein de l'éventuelle
commission mix pariaire chargé
d'élaborer un texte soit disposition
restant dans la discussion du projet de
loi de financement rectificative de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 ont été
publiés ces candidatures seront
ratifiées si la présidence n'a pas reçu
d'opposition dans le délai d'une heure
prévue par notre règlement
j'informe également le Sénat que les
candidatures pour sierger au sein de la
commission mixte paritaire chargée
d'élaborer un texte sur les dispositions
restantes en discussions de la
proposition de loi tendant à renforcer
l'équilibre dans les relations
commerciales entre fournisseurs et
distributeurs ont été publiés ces
candidatures seront ratifiées si la
présidence n'a pas reçu d'opposition
dans le délai d'une heure prévue par
notre règlement mes chers collègues les
conclusions adoptées par la Conférence
des Présidents réunis ce jour sont
consultables sur le site du Sénat en
l'absence d'observation je considère ces
conclusions comme adopter
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je suis heureux de saluer la présence de
nos tribunes des auditrices et des
auditeurs de la sixième promotion de
l'Institut du Sénat
[Applaudissements]
à l'initiative de notre ancien collègue
Jean Léonce Dupont le bureau du Sénat
avait décidé en 2015 de mettre en œuvre
ce programme de formation en vue de
mieux faire connaître les modalités de
fonctionnement et les enjeux de notre
démocratie parlementaire à des
personnalités d'horizon géographique et
professionnelles très diverses
les 18 auditeurs de cette sixième
promotion issue d'une dizaine de
départements différents représentent en
effet les sphères d'activité
professionnelle publique économiques
agricoles sportives éducatives
universitaire ou encore scientifique
tout au long de leur travaux qui ont
commencé ce matin et s'agront fin juin
il rencontreront plusieurs de nos
collègues sénateurs et des
fonctionnaires du Sénat en votre nom à
tous je leur souhaite une excellente
session au Sénat et je suis certain qu'à
l'issue de ces trois mois ils pourront
être les témoins privilégiés de la
placer de notre institution au sein de
la Cinquième République et de la qualité
du travail parlementaire
[Applaudissements]
alors l'ordre du jour appelle la suite
de la discussion du projet de loi de
financement rectificative de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023
j'ai quelques rappels au règlement tout
d'abord le président Laurent
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
rappel au règlement qui s'appuie sur
l'article 44 bis du règlement parmi les
mesures déclenchées cette nuit pour
accélérer la clôture autoritaire des
débats sur l'article 7 et sur le projet
de loi retraite la commission des
affaires sociales a invoqué l'article 44
bis du règlement pour déclarer
irrecevable plusieurs centaines de sous
amendements qui ont été déposés après la
réécriture de l'article 7 qui sont
devenus subitement irrecevables alors
que les amendements qu'il reproduisaient
avaient eux étaient déclarés recevables
par la même commission la présidente de
roche sur la figure au compte-rendu a
d'ailleurs reconnu qu'il s'agissait des
mêmes amendements mais le vice-président
karucci nous a en quelque sorte livré
l'explication de texte
à partir du moment où l'article réécrit
était devenu un amendement cela rendait
soi-disant impossible de le sous-amender
en le on contestant le sens
effectivement le règlement 40 bis rend
impossible au dépôt d'un sous amendement
qui soit contraire à l'amendement auquel
il s'applique mais c'est en l'occurrence
un détournement de sens du règlement car
si nous acceptons cette interprétation
il suffit alors de transformer un
article entier et ça a été le cas cette
nuit on en abondement on le réécrivant
pour le rendre inabondable c'est-à-dire
l'article qui est lui-même
constitutionnellement amendable et
contestable devient par le jeu d'une
réécriture on amendement un article
inammendable c'est donc une atteinte de
fait à la capacité et au droit
constitutionnels d'amendement des
parlementaires
il faut donc être extrêmement vigilant
mes chers collègues vers sur ce
précédent car c'est un précédent qui a
été créé et qui ouvre la porte à toutes
les manipulations contre le droit
d'amendement et jeudi aux républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président mon rappel
au règlement se fonde sur l'article 44
de la Constitution les membres du
Parlement et le gouvernement ont le
droit d'amendement cette nuit en effet
des sous amendements ont été déclarés
irrecevables sans même avoir été examiné
en commission de la veux même de sa
présidence nombre des notes portaient
sur des précisions techniques
manifestement parfaitement recevable ce
droit inaliénable d'amendement a été
utilisé par la commission pour
reformuler l'article 7 dans une version
quasi identique au texte originel dans
le seul but de faire disparaître les
amendements des groupes de gauche qui
relaient ici les préoccupations de nos
concitoyens mobilisés très massivement
encore hier ces amendements portés par
exemple sur l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation sur le report de l'âge légal
de départ en retraite ces sujets que
vous nous disiez vouloir débattre que
vraiment entendu ici sur l'examen de ce
texte à l'Assemblée nationale mais ce
qui se passe ici même au Sénat et
l'autre face d'une même pièce empêcher
le travail parlementaire sur ce texte et
cela non non pas le Sénat où est passé
la sagesse que vous convoquez
régulièrement
où est la rigueur légendaire du Sénat
disparu dans de basses manœuvres qui
n'effaceront pas nous vous le disons mes
chers collègues la détermination du
peuple français a rejeté cette réforme
et cette très très mauvaise réforme
merci chers collègues monsieur gay
pour un rappel au règlement
merci monsieur le Président sur le même
article
je m'exprime devant vous avec solennité
mes chers collègues et une colère froide
nos débats sont très suivis à
l'extérieur beaucoup nous ont dit qu'il
comptait sur nous tout et tous pour
échanger avoir un débat de fond et pour
notre paragua gauche nous y opposer pour
les faire échec car nous sommes dans
l'opposition depuis jeudi nous pensons
que nous faisons la politique en ayant
un débat argumenté précisé documenté ce
qui est bien le rôle du Parlement tant
que nous sommes pas passés à la Sixième
République et changer de constitution
chaque parlementaire a le droit de
déposer un amendement et de le défendre
même si la droite accusée la gauche
d'une obstruction cordiale et qu'en
réponse nous vous renvoyons celle d'une
obstruction
silencieuse nous avions dans le débat
celui que nous avons eu dimanche projet
comme projet répartition contre
capitalisation a été utile je le pense
qui peut dire ici que nous avons perdu
du temps c'est pour ça que hier nous
avons été très sûrs
38 reste régnant la parole puis la
réécriture de l'article 7 rendant
innamandable cet article et enfin
déclarant nos amendements devenus sous
amendements
anticonstitutionnel pour question
d'égalité alors qu'une demi-heure avant
il ne l'était pas sans pourvoir nous
l'expliquer si on y rajoute les
décisions pris ce matin avec de
nouvelles dispositions pour réduire une
nouvelle fois le temps de parole c'est
un coup de force coup de force certes
permis par le règlement mais le
règlement n'est que là pour organiser
notre vie commune lorsqu'on l'utilise
pour régler une question politique c'est
que nous sommes au bord d'une crise
démocratique en fait l'utilisation de
toutes ces règles prouve votre fébrilité
et monde que vous avez besoin
d'autoritarisme pour établir votre
autorité politique vous avez perdu et
vous le savez vous êtes minoritaire
alors que chacun sera sur ici que celles
et ceux qui luttent dehors nous restons
utile et déterminés ici comme samedi
prochain pour le retrait de ce projet
[Applaudissements]
ceci est un rappel au règlement même
arctique 44 bis en effet le recours
exceptionnel exceptionnel à l'article 38
du Règlement Intérieur et cela en pleine
nuit le jour même d'une mobilisation
historique de grande ampleur contre
cette réforme des retraites écrit main
dans la main avec le gouvernement nous
sommes constitués une attaque en règle
et particulièrement grave de notre
démocratie parlementaire cet article
clôture en effet un débat parlementaire
d'une façon qui ne Nort pas notre
institution j'ai bien entendu madame la
Première ministre tout à l'heure qui a
invoquait la séparation des pouvoirs
pourtant nous ne pouvons que constater
la constitution ou du moins le
renforcement de ce bloc de droit libéral
comme une sorte de remaniement
ministériel qui annoncerait de futurs
changements institutionnels mais dans
quel régime politique nous trouvons nous
ces pratiques sont honteuses parce que
si vous êtes en train de préparer en
douce encore une fois un changement
institutionnel synonyme d'un nouveau
régime politique et bien dites-le nous
et vous n'ignorez pas vous ignorez avec
arrogance et déconsidérations la colère
des Françaises et les Français et c'est
pourtant difficile de ne pas voir que
personne ne veut perdre ses deux plus
belles années de retraite pour prendre
deux années de travail les plus
difficiles le même jour de la journée
internationale de lutte pour les droits
des femmes vous apprêtez à faire passer
en force par un coup de force
institutionnel un article l'article 7
qui pénalisera en premier lieu les
femmes et vous le savez et là je voulais
m'adresser à monsieur le président
Gérard Larcher qu'il m'écoute monsieur
le président Gérard Larcher dans la nuit
d'hier vous avez été davantage le
président DLR que le président du Sénat
en se soumettant en se soumettant à
l'agenda du gouvernement avec cet
article 38 article réclamé par le
président retaillod et applaudi par les
centristes monsieur le Président Larcher
vous décrébilisez notre institution et
le travail parlementaire
je m'adresse donc à ce nouveau blog de
droit merci chers soyez raisonnable
soirée pour retirer cette réforme merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole était président
merci merci monsieur le Président
rappelle au Règlement sur la base de la
décision du 11 juin 2015 du Conseil
constitutionnel sur le caractère
effectif de l'exercice du droit
d'amendement et les exigences de clarté
de sincérité du débat parlementaire en
effet ça ça vient encore être appelé
plusieurs éléments ont été
particulièrement problématiques lors de
la dernière séance de notre assemblée ou
araignée c'est moins qu'on puisse dire
une très grande confusion la liste est
donc et mes collègues poursuivrons sur
le le la liste des irrigarités la
commission notamment n'a pas réellement
examiné les sous amendements de la vue
même de la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales la présidente de
la commission des affaires sociales a
déclaré ne pas avoir examiné certains
sous amendements comme La Teste
compte-rendu analytique de la séance à
sa page 69 mais a ensuite déclaré
irrecevable c'est même sous amendements
pour ensuite déclarer les avoir examinés
ce qui est matériellement impossible la
Commission n'a pas citer le bon
fondement pour déclarer les sous
amendements irrecevables en raison de
leur soi-disant contradiction avec
l'amendement de réécriture c'est
l'article 44 bis 3 pour seul fondement
qui a été cité alors aurait dû être
invoqué l'article 44 bis Ali à neuf
invoquant les motifs prévus à l'article
44 bis Alina 4 la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales a omis
des informations elle n'a cité aucun
article du règlement pour déclarer les
sous amendements d'exception de
différents métiers irrecevables alors
qu'elle aurait dûment énoncer qu'elle se
fondait sur lactique 44 bis alien A10
elle a également anticipé la décision du
Sénat en déclarant y recevable ses
amendements alors qu'elle a été fondée
qu'à demander que le Sénat se prononce
sur leur seul irrévocable il
recevabilité enfin la présidence de
séance n'a pas éclairci la procédure ni
garantit la clarté la sincérité des
débats la distinction entre les deux
formes d'irrégularité leur fondement
réglementaire n'a pas non plus été
spécifiée par la présidence il aurait
été il aurait été pardon souhaitable
qu'il précise les différents fondements
et les amendements concernés enfin
certains sous amendements ont finalement
été discutés en séance sans être
distribué afin que les sénateurs
puissent s'en saisir ils ont été rejetés
par le Sénat pour finalement merci
d'être déclaré il recevable imposteuris
c'est le cas du sous-amendement 4765
merci monsieur le Président sur le même
article et sur la même décision du 11
juin 2015 du Conseil constitutionnel sur
les exigences de clarté et de sincérité
des débats parlementaires l'organisation
de la séance la nuit dernière à nuit à
la
qui s'est déroulé dans la confusion
absolue à perturber la clarté des débats
les droits ouverts au sénateur par le
réglement intérieur n'ont pas été
respectées la séance a refusé des
rappels au règlement en parfaite
contradiction avec l'article 36 alinéa 3
du règlement qui dispose pourtant que la
parole est accordée sur le champ à tous
sénateurs qu'il a demandé pour un rappel
au règlement de plus les sénateurs ont
dû voter dans la précipitation et la
confusion sur une motion qu'il n'avait
pas sous les yeux la version papier de
la motion tendant opposé l'exception d'y
recevoirbilité n'a pas été distribué au
sénateur avant le vote la volonté de
passer en force n'excuse n'excuse pas
tout il faut en tenir compte je vous
remercie merci chers collègues Madame De
Marco
différentes ou qu'il dérochent au
principe d'égalité pour des raisons
d'intérêt général le principe d'égalité
n'est en aucun cas un principe absolu et
vous pouvez affirme vous ne pouvez
affirmer avec certitude que ces
amendements étaient incanties
inconstitutionnel seul le Conseil
constitutionnel aurait pu le faire
nous nous demandons également pourquoi
il n'a pas été invoqué que ce motif pour
demander d'y recevoir d'habilité de nos
amendements dans les dispositifs sens
similaires monsieur le Président quand
on se livre un coup de force
réglementaire comme cela a été opéré
hier il est préférable d'être d'une
incontestable rigueur
pour reprendre sereinement l'examen de
ce projet de loi le Sénat sonorerait à
annuler toutes les opérations de vote
qui ont eu lieu après la reprise de 1h45
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur A souligne
monsieur le Président rappeller au
règlement aussi ce référent à la
délibération du 11 juin 2015 du Conseil
constitutionnel alors
ce que l'on a vu cette nuit n'est pas
anodin et restera comme un moment
historique pour cette assemblée
pour tous ceux qui sont là depuis un
certain temps ils n'ont jamais vu ça et
ils le disent il y a eu des moments de
tension des moments de combat des
moments de rappel à des règlements de
bataille de procédures ça c'est la vie
des assemblées par contre l'arbitraire
qui tombe d'un coup avec cette violence
au milieu de la nuit qui vient supprimer
des milliers d'amendements et ensuite
des milliers de sous amendements en
moins de trois quarts d'heure c'est à
dire avec l'impossibilité matérielle et
je demanderai des vérifications si
est-ce que matériellement c'est possible
et s'il faut une enquête on peut la
faire
de vérifier que les 2000 amendements
n'étaient pas recevables
alors vous avez fait tout ça mais
attention ce n'est peut-être pas un
service que vous rendez au gouvernement
parce que ce qui a frappé l'opinion
requin mobilisée aussi beaucoup c'est
que à l'Assemblée nationale cet article
central qui est la loi c'est toute la
loi tout le reste n'existe pas s'il n'y
a pas cette mesure qui fait un impôt sur
la vie de deux ans sur la vie des
Français
il y a pas eu de discussion à
l'Assemblée nationale tout le monde
attendait qu'elle ait lieu là
et c'est sur cet article pas sur les
autres il y a eu près de 50 heures de
discussion ici tranquille sur tous les
autres
et c'est sur celui-là ou la France
attendait un débat que le couperait est
tombé et bien le Conseil constitutionnel
pourra apprécier la sincérité des débats
et des libérations si aucune des deux
assemblées n'a pu discuter sérieusement
sur le fond de l'article 7 la parole est
à madame la Présidente rossignol
on rappellerament est aussi fondé sur un
type 44 bis le Conseil constitutionnel a
deux exigences à l'égard de nos travaux
la clarté et la sincérité je vais
examiner ce qui s'est passé hier à
l'aune de ces deux conditions en ce qui
concerne la sincérité de l'amendement
déposé par Monsieur Savary hier soir
nous avons longuement discuté en
commission monsieur Savary a longuement
développé l'article 7 le soutien qui lui
apportait jamais jamais il n'a été
question d'un amendement du rapporteur
réécrivant une partie de cet article 7
cet amendement est sorti hier soir à
2h30 du matin uniquement uniquement pour
priver le Sénat du débat qu'il attendait
sur l'article 7 donc je commence par
dire que c'est un sincère
c'est une manœuvre en ce qui concerne la
clarté nous avons voté le nous avons
voté le Sénat a voté des sénateurs ont
voté hier soir cette nuit dans la plus
grande confusion c'est amendement entre
deux suspensions de séance au moment où
nous cherchions encore qu'elles étaient
les conséquences de l'adoption
éventuelle de cet amendement par le
Sénat sur les amendements que nous
avions déposés précédemment au moment où
on nous informait que nous sous
amendements que nous étions en train de
déposer était contraire à l'amendement
déposé par Monsieur Savary contraire
changer une date c'est contraire depuis
quand depuis quand changer une date dans
un amendement est contraire c'était
l'objet de certains de notre sous
amendements donc hier soir vous avez
voté
un amendement dans des conditions qui ne
respectent ni l'exigence de sincérité ni
l'exigence de clarté que le Conseil
constitutionnel nous demande merci chers
collègues monsieur
[Applaudissements]
le président mon rappelle au règlement
se fonde sur l'article 44 bis alinéa 4
il est dit dans cet article que les sous
amendements
sont recevables à condition
de n'avoir pas pour effet de contredire
l'amendement
auquel il se rapporte
or parmi les sous amendements qui ont
été déposés il en est un grand nombre
qui ne contredisent pas l'amendement
auquel il se rapporte il est
parfaitement légitime de déposer des
sous amendements qui limitent l'effet de
l'amendement qui réduisent la portée de
l'amendement qui réduisent les
conséquences de l'amendement qui
complètent ce que dit l'amendement tout
cela est légitime ce n'est pas une
contradiction donc monsieur le Président
j'ai l'honneur de vous demander
que qu'il soit procédé à un examen de
l'ensemble des sous amendements
que l'on puisse voir
sous amendement
s'il y a contradiction car la Commission
a été en un quart d'heure dans
l'impossibilité de le faire de telle
manière que tous les sous amendements
qui ne sont pas contradictoires à
l'amendement viennent en sciences
publiques sinon c'est un véritable déni
par rapport au droit fondamental à
l'amendement et au sous-amendement qui
est le d'autres merci chers collègues la
parole est au président canner
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre à mon tour sur la base de
l'article 44 bis et l'ensemble de ces
alinéas ce qui s'est passé hier soir et
particulièrement
il est dit au sein du Sénat je ne
reviendrai pas sur les arguments qui ont
été développés par mes collègues il y a
un instant simplement il y a un contexte
et ce contexte est aggravé ce matin par
la Conférence des Présidents
article 38 ne relève pas de l'autorité
de la Conférence des Présidents le la
décision de d'utiliser les amendements
prioritaires rectif non plus par contre
l'article 42 peut être déclenché sur la
base d'une décision de la Conférence des
Présidents nous nous sommes opposés
parce qu'il concerne les bancs de cette
musique mais la décision a été prise ce
qui veut dire monsieur le Président que
ce droit d'amendement est sous
amendement aujourd'hui pour ce qui reste
de notre débat va être encadré comme
jamais au Sénat par votre décision et
par votre capacité à vouloir plier je le
dis les arguments de notre opposition
ici représentée je le regrette c'est une
image mauvaise qui a été donnée hier
soir tous les arguments développés par
Madame Rossignol feront naturellement
d'une réflexion vis-à-vis d'un éventuel
recours devant le Conseil
constitutionnel je ne sais pas si je
peux vous dire de vous ressaisir en tout
cas ce que je sais oui vous ressaisir
vous pour que le débat puisse aller
jusqu'au bout dans les meilleurs
conditions tous ces rappels au règlement
n'ont qu'un objectif
mes chers collègues tous ces règlements
dans un seul objectif faire que le Sénat
puisse travailler dans de bonnes
conditions un texte aussi important pour
nos concitoyens c'est la volonté qui est
la nôtre je ne suis pas sûr qu'elle soit
partagée par vous toutes merci chers
collègues la parole est à Madame de La
Gontrie
merci monsieur le Président tous ceux
qui ont participé nous étions nombreux à
la séance de nuit ont pu constater
l'extrême désordre dans lequel le Sénat
a tenté de travailler et tout cela sera
examiné de près évidemment par le
Conseil constitutionnel notre collègue
Laurence rossinol a rappelé comment le
Conseil a dans ses jurisprudences
successives instaurer désormais la
nécessité du respect de la sincérité de
la clarté du débat parlementaire nous
aurons sûrement l'occasion de revenir
sur ce principe
ultérieurement lors de nos débats je le
sens mais je voudrais revenir sur la
façon dont les sous-abendements ont été
traités plusieurs collègues l'ont fait
mais je voudrais compléter ces ces
commentaires lorsque madame la
Présidente de roche a donc fait
connaître lire ce habilité décrétée on
peut dire les choses comme ça sur des
sous amendements qu'il n'avaient jamais
été même lu par la commission il s'est
passé un phénomène encore plus
caricatural à 3 heures du matin le
groupe
communiste a déposé de nouveaux sous
amendements en nombre et
la présidente de la commission dit les
choses suivantes telles que repris dans
le compte rendu analytique je cite
d'autres sous amendements viennent
d'être déposés dans la même veine ils
sont pareillement contradiction avec
l'amendement du rapporteur les mêmes
causes produisant les mêmes effets la
Commission les déclare donc irrecevables
donc nous avons vu une présidente de
commission à son banc avec des avec des
amendements qu'elle n'avait même pas vu
ni lu décrété que par principe ils
étaient irrecevables en contradiction
totale avec le règlement et la
recevabilité des 10 sous amendements
nous demandons donc que l'ensemble de
ces sous amendements soit premièrement
examiner formellement par la commission
deuxièmement que leur irrecevabilité
soit explicité et que infini il soit
réellement examiné par le Sénat
merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
nous prenons acte de tous ces rappels au
règlement
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois françois-Noël Buffet
malgré tout il faudrait redire ce qui
s'est passé hier soir hier soir leur
rapporteur a déposé un amendement
réécrivant totalement les dispositions
une partie de l'article 7 c'est sur la
base de cette réécriture que nos
collègues de l'opposition ont déposé
3000 amendements ils ont admis soumis
pardon qui se sont leurs anciens
amendements qui se sont traduits en
sous-amendement en réalité ils ont donc
changé de nature
tous les moyens en
sa possession pour pouvoir s'opposer au
vote du texte mais mais
il a été dit également par les
représentants de l'opposition que la
majorité pouvait aussi utiliser les
moyens qui étaient à sa disposition au
sein du règlement pour voter le texte
donc voilà la réalité du débat
d'aujourd'hui
alors monsieur Durand a demandé la
parole et Madame Linde et puis ensuite
il y aura une réponse de Madame de roche
et puis ensuite on passera l'examen des
amendements
merci monsieur le Président
que nous n'allions pas au bout de
l'examen du texte ça pourrait presque
favoriser certains membres de la
majorité sanatoriale qui sont bien
embarrassées par cette situation
deuxième point que je voulais aborder
c'est cette formule qu'a eu la
présidente de roche hier c'est à la page
69 du compte-rendu analytique
elle dit la même motion s'appliquerait
au nouveau sous amendement reçu trois
petits points Pierre Laurent dit alors
on est à la lumière elle est restée
allumée Madame Catherine de roche
reprend y compris ceux que la Commission
n'a pas eu le temps d'examiner en effet
ils sont donc ils sont dans la même
veine que les précédents alors qu'on
oppose les recevabilité à des
amendements qu'on a lu pourquoi pas mais
qu'on insère de l'état d'esprit de nos
groupes le contenu d'amendement me
paraît extrêmement grave
cher collègue madame Lehmann
oui monsieur buffet nous explique qu'une
partie des amendements devenus sous
amendements changer de nature parce que
il y avait nécessité de cohérence si je
puis dire avec le contenu de
l'amendement
n'est vrai que pour une partie du
raisonnement développé par Madame de
roche car l'autre il y a un paquet
qu'elle a motivé avec ses motifs on le
conteste mais celui-là à la limite on
peut en discuter en revanche l'autre
partie elle est ils ont été
retoqués j'allais dire juger et
recevable au motif de l'égalité du
non-respect de l'égalité républicaine
mais ça ça motive de contenu
constitutionnel qui ne change pas de
nature quand on a un amendement ou un
sous amendement
soit l'amendement respecte l'égalité
républicaine potentiellement et quand il
devient sous amendement il change pas de
nature au regard de ce critère
RSI proprement donc
madame la Présidente de roche
merci monsieur le président
donc
on va revenir si vous me laissez parler
ce serait mieux c'est pas votre habitude
ça j'ai remarqué mais en fin de temps en
temps forcez-vous un peu voilà
[Applaudissements]
en présentant la motion qui tendait à
opposer l'exception des recevabilité je
voudrais revenir brièvement en effet sur
les questions qui ont été soulevées au
cours du débat d'hier sur la régularité
de la procédure tout d'abord comment
l'exception d'y recevabilité bien prévue
par notre règlement et jusqu'à sa
récente réforme les commissions avaient
notamment recours pour proposer au Sénat
de déclarer et recevable des amendements
qui créent une habilitation du
gouvernement à légiféré par ordonnance
ou allergir le champ d'une ordonnance
d'une façon générale l'exception du
recevabilité permet au Sénat de ne pas
examiner des amendements ou des sous
amendements contraire à la Constitution
je l'ai dit clairement hier et là c'est
le pourquoi les amendements
que l'amendement de la commission a fait
tomber hier soir était des amendements
d'obstruction catalogue des professions
suppression d'alinéa en rafale après
l'examen des 77
dans ce calme on se calme on a encore la
soirée donc ne commencez pas vous
énerver ils sont d'ailleurs assez
classiques et on peut les retrouver dans
les différentes réformes de retraite
leur seul objet est dilatoire les
amendements portant sur le fond du texte
ont été préservés c'était l'objet de
l'amendement du rapporteur ça varie
c'était de faire tomber en effet tous
ces amendements dilatoires et de pouvoir
se consacrer et de pouvoir se consacrer
au fond du texte et un vrai débat qui
intéresse nos concitoyens
les sous amendements déposés en masque
quelques minutes après le dépôt de
l'amendement du rapporteur était les
mêmes si parce que je suis passé du
temps ce qui est en commission bien vu
que je n'étais pas au début de la
commission j'étais dans la salle où en
examinait tous les amendements
d'ailleurs au départ vous avez présenté
non pas des sous amendements mais ils
étaient intitulés amendement vous savez
très bien que non non madame on peut les
ressortir
on peut les ressortir
des amendements bref président de vous
finissez et il y a eu des
sous-amendements qui ont été déposés en
effet certains groupes ne se sont au
demeurant même pas la peine de les
modifier c'est ce que je vous dis par
leur nombre et leur objet et poursuivait
le même objectif que les amendements
empêcher le déroulement de la discussion
a gagné du temps ces
amendements de production ont été
déposés conformément au règlement mais
l'exception d'y recevabilité l'est aussi
nous assumons nous aussi de répondre à
l'obstruction permise par le règlement
par les moyens permis par le règlement
la clarté des débats il y a une
certainement lorsque nous sortons ces
longs tunnel de discussion qui n'ont
d'autres objets que de refaire à l'envie
la discussion générale et nous ce que
nous souhaitons c'est passer à l'examen
des articles sur le fond le camp
certains orateurs
en monsieur monsieur
vraiment monsieur Assouline si vous
pouvez aujourd'hui je voulais dire
arrêtez de hurler en permanence
si mais si vous rendez même pas compte
on dit toujours que lorsqu'on hurle
c'est qu'on n'a pas beaucoup d'arguments
certains orateurs se sont étonnés que
l'exception d'y recevabilité arrive
après l'examen en commission et soit
opposé à des sous amendements
identiques à des amendements examinés
par la conique la commission
reconnaissant ainsi qu'il s'agit c'est
bien des mêmes vous l'avez dit et qu'il
ne faites donc pas des heures à la
Commission pour les examiner je voudrais
tout d'abord rappeler qu'un amendement
recevable ne fait pas forcément ça a été
dit un sous amendement recevable un
amendement unifie le texte un sous
amendement modifié un amendement dont il
ne doit pas contredire le sens et c'est
ce que vous contestez mais on pourrait
je voudrais ensuite indiquer que
l'exception d'y recevabilité s'oppose en
séance et que ce n'est pas parce qu'un
amendement est examiné en commission
qu'elle ne peut pas par la suite lui
être opposé en séance c'est ce que nous
avons fait et je peux vous dire que pour
être allé dans la salle où les
amendements étaient examinés il y avait
un nombre très important important
d'administrateur et aucun amendement
n'est passé dans les mailles du filet
merci ma présidente monsieur le
rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
effectivement je partage je partage une
partie de vos propos il y a eu 48 heures
48 heures de discussions depuis quelques
jours avant d'arriver à cet article 7
il y a eu
deux
articles déterminants pour cette réforme
des retraites à savoir
l'article 1 qui ferme les régimeux
spéciaux
nous étions favorables de ce côté là
vous étiez défavorable le première
partie et puis après vous avez proposé
des dates de fermeture un peu plus
tardives mais vous avez proposé la
fermeture des services des régimes
spéciaux comme quoi parfois on peut se
retrouver et puis il y a eu sur
l'article 2
la discussion importante le départ sur
l'emploi des seniors avec des
propositions venant du gouvernement pour
certaines l'index des seniors venant de
ces bancs là pour d'autres le CDI senior
et vous vous êtes opposés vous vous êtes
opposé à cela et c'est votre droit ces
débats ont duré 4 heures sur 48 heures
sur 48 heures de discussion 4 heures de
débat car effectivement le reste était
un monologue où vous présentiez votre
vision très apocalyptique du monde du
travail avec votre volonté de vous
opposer sans présenter vos amendements
car si nous avions entendu la
présentation de ces amendements je pense
que ceux qui nous écoutent auraient
changé d'avis
et puis ensuite vous dire
vous dire que effectivement vous avez eu
un effet de surprise mais la vivacité de
lecture de madame la Présidente pour
juger de la recevabilité
de leur homme sevabilité de ses
amendements est identique à votre vie
vas-y des pour proposer dans la minute
3000 sous amendements
quel effet de surprise
n'y avait-il pas quelque part une
préparation
on pourrait penser contenu de ce qui se
passe qu'au départ que nous ayons des
discussions que l'on vous soupçonne de
vouloir vous entraver au bon déroulé des
débats mais quand on ressort 3000
amendements c'est qu'on veut s'opposer
au débat et en conséquence dites-le
clairement dites-le nous ne voulons pas
voter cette réforme nous ne voulons pas
débattre sur un sujet sociétal et arrivé
au vote mais dites-le n'hésitez pas
on avait Claude les rappels au règlement
il y a eu des réponses qui ont été
apportées nous allons maintenant passer
dans la discussion des articles
écoutez je pense qu'on a laissé 90
monsieur le Président vous êtes
intervenus déjà sur le rappel au
règlement il n'y a pas une deuxième
intervention
ce n'est pas j'entends la demande de
suspension mais c'est à mon appréciation
c'est la prestation du président de
séance de savoir s'il faut suspendre ou
pas la séance mais donc
je vais la suspendre 5 minutes monsieur
le Président la séance 5 minutes
monsieur le Président je vous demande
[Musique]
chers collègues la séance est reprise
le président Kanner pour une courte
intervention oui très courte monsieur le
Président je ration de nos collègues
mais je n'ai pas eu le temps de vous
dire pourquoi je souhaite une
interaction de science vous avez été
tellement rapide sur la cloche que bon
ce que nous souhaitions c'est que la
Commission de la science sociale puisse
réunir et puis se balayer l'ensemble des
sous amendements qui ont été déclarés
irrecevable
je pense que si j'avais pu vous demander
cela vous me l'auriez refusé donc merci
pour la suspension préalable merci donc
la suspension n'a pas permis la
commission de regarder mais enfin ça a
été regardé par la présidente elle l'a
dit tout à l'heure
donc on va on va commencer comme le
souhaitait la plupart d'entre vous
discuter sur le fond sur l'article 7 et
donc on a un certain nombre
d'amendements en discussion commune dont
un certain nombre ont été retirés dont
un certain nombre ont été retirés donc
l'amendement 165 230 ont été retirés
nous avons le 1142 de Monsieur
Ménonville
est-ce qu'il est là Monsieur
mélenonville non il a retiré le 2496
madame Boyer a été retiré donc nous
passons au 263 madame Lubin qui le
défend
qui ne défend cet amendement
même les bain
merci monsieur le Président moi j'ai
proposé un amendement avec mon groupe
qui tend au lieu de donner une surcote
de 5% aux femmes qui arrivent avec tous
leurs trimestres à l'âge de 63 ans
donc leur permettre d'avoir 5 % de plus
quand elles prennent leur retraite à 64
ans ce qui n'est pas ce qui n'est pas
tout à fait juste à nos yeux dans la
mesure où aujourd'hui une femme qui
arrive à 62 ans avec tous ces trimestres
et qui décident volontairement de
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans peut avoir 10%
de surcotte donc là avec cette
proposition au final elle perd 5% de
surcote donc nous ce que nous proposons
ça serait bien si vous pouvez avoir un
peu de silence à côté s'il vous plaît
merci et donc non mais c'est difficile
c'est
c'est c'est
difficile de parler au micro c'est
difficile de parler
[Musique]
gauche qui est ça aussi le cher collègue
c'est mon nom c'est mon oreille gauche
qui est sensible pardon et donc et donc
moi ce que je ce que je propose c'est
que pour les femmes qui ont des
trimestres qui ont eu des enfants et qui
peuvent valider des trimestres
supplémentaires qui à 62 ans ont tout
leur trimestres qu'elles prennent leur
retraite à 62 ans puisque de toute façon
elles ont la durée totale grâce au
trimestre qu'elles auront acquis pour
enfants voilà c'est un amendement qui me
paraît comment dire maman demande de
justice et de logique quelque part voilà
le 1961 monsieur Chassin
il est retiré donc on a pu en fait qu'un
un seul amendement puisque le 2189 a été
retiré le 168 aussi le 1972 aussi le
2190 aussi donc sur cet amendement
2633 la commission la vie de la
Commission
oui merci effectivement c'est
intéressant de penser à cette carrière
des mers de famille qui se traduit
derrière par des pensions qui sont pas
toujours à la hauteur et les majorations
de
les majorations d'assurance qui sont
accordées pour les maires de famille
sont effectivement tout à fait
intéressantes à la fois pour combler la
carrière et aider à arriver au taux
plein mais également pour avoir une
reconnaissance par rapport à cette
volonté de concilier une carrière et une
maternité elles sont cependant
différentes entre le régime public et
privé puisque c'est quatre trimestres
pour la maternité plus 4 trimestres à
distribuer pour l'éducation des enfants
d'un côté et seulement deux trimestres
dans le régime public donc c'est
apprendre en compte la différence madame
Lubin entre un âge avancé de départ d'un
an et une surcote c'est-à-dire qu'on
continue à travailler comparé à 64 ans
et à ce moment là ce que nous proposons
c'est de prendre en compte cette effort
supplémentaire et de le récompenser
l'avantage c'est que on va dans la
philosophie de la réforme que
voulez-vous c'est quand même les
Français l'ont bien compris travailler
plus et un deuxième avantage par hassas
c'est que ça augmente la pension de ces
femmes ça réduit l'écart entre les
niveaux de pension entre les hommes et
les femmes c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons choisi ce dispositif et qui
argument supplémentaire me semble-t-il
permet de pas être discriminatoire par
rapport à la Cour européenne si vous
faites un âge avancé pour les femmes
réservées aux femmes il y a une
différence de traitement par rapport aux
hommes c'est la raison pour laquelle
notre amendement je vous invite à le
soutenir et vraiment la meilleure
solution par rapport à ces difficultés
que peuvent rencontrer les maires de
famille donc c'est un invité favorable
sur des monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président de madame la
Présidente de la Commission madame et
monsieur le rapporteur la vie du
Gouvernement est défavorable pour
plusieurs raisons la première concerne
cette question d'égalité que monsieur le
rapporteur vient d'évoquer je n'y
reviens pas il y a une deuxième raison
qui est relève de la mécanique même de
l'amendement que Madame Libin défendu la
surcotte quand on parle de surcote est
accessible aujourd'hui et elle sera
demain dans les mêmes conditions à deux
conditions cumulatives la première est
d'atteindre d'avoir atteint l'âge
d'ouverture des droits tel que fixés au
régime général et la deuxième est
d'avoir atteint la durée d'affiliation
au régime requise pour pouvoir faire
valoir ses droits à taux plein et c'est
vraiment ces deux conditions qu'il y a
une possibilité de surcote et donc une
surcote qui intervient après la od et à
condition d'avoir l'intégralité des
trimestres requis pour demander aux
bénéficier d'une retraite à taux plein
il y a une difficulté dans l'amendement
que vous présentez madame la sénatrice
qui consiste à imaginer créer des âges
différenciés finalement non pas entre
les femmes et les hommes mais tel que
vous le présentez entre les mères et les
hommes puisqu'il faudrait bénéficier de
trimestre au titre de la maternité je le
dis de manière un peu rapide pour
pouvoir bénéficier d'un âge avancé notre
préférence va un amendement adopter par
la commission des affaires sociales dont
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de parler qui a
été initié par le président Retailleau
parce qu'il permet de cumuler les
avantages de deux systèmes premier
avantage et qu'il permet pour des femmes
qui ont une carrière hachée nous savons
que les femmes sont plus exposées que
les hommes en cariaché de pouvoir
continuer à mettre en oeuvre et utiliser
des trimestres validé au titre de la
maternité pour compléter leur durée
d'affiliation requise et ainsi pouvoir
partir à l'âge d'ouverture des droits
dans 900 les conditions de fixation de
celui-ci à ton plan et sans décote c'est
un élément de protection parce que ça
permet justement d'éviter la décote pour
des femmes en cariacées tentait que le
nombre de trimestres ainsi validé est
suffisant la deuxième utilisation qui
permet cet amendement adopté par la
commission des affaires sociales et de
dire que si un assuré
plus généralement une assurée mais c'est
générique a atteint à la fois l'âge de
63 ans et dans le même temps la durée
d'affiliation requise 168 trimestre
aujourd'hui 172 demain en 2027 il y a
non pas la possibilité mais
automatiquement une surcote pour les
trimestres cotisés entre les 63 ans si
tenté que la Dar était éteinte et les 64
ans ce qui est l'échelle d'une année
représente une majoration non pas des
trimestres mais de la totalité de la
pension de 5% hauteur de 1,25% par
trimestre et donc la préférence du
gouvernement et ça justifiera la vie
favorable ultérieurement à l'amendement
adopté par la commission tient au fait
que par cette amendement nous gardons le
bénéfice d'une majoration de durée pour
les assurer principalement les femmes
ayant une carrière hachée ou incomplète
à la fin et que nous pouvons prévoir une
possibilité de surcote pour celle qui a
une carrière complète et ça répond à une
évolution de société évolution de
société qui fait que le taux d'emploi
des femmes a progressé c'est heureux et
qui fait que la conciliation de la vie
professionnelle avec la maternité
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues nous
sommes aujourd'hui le 8 mars journée
internationale de lutte pour le droit
des femmes c'est quand même ça tombe
très bien c'est amendement et on le sait
on le dit et c'est répété ce sont les
femmes qui vont être les grandes pertes
de ce projet de réforme de départ et de
recul de l'âge de des pâtes de départ à
la retraite que cet amendement et bien
je le voterai puisque en termes de
financement c'est un texte de
financement là il y a pas de surcoût et
pas plus coûteux qu'une surcotte de 5%
qui est prévue par l'amendement déposé
par René Paul Savary et sur le fond
encore une fois par rapport à ce projet
de loi injuste et injuste surtout envers
les femmes je voterai l'amendement de
présenté par mon groupe et Monique
cubain en premier et puis je pose une
question qui m'étonne qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce débat où tous les
amendements se retirent avant d'être
discuté où est l'esprit du débat du
Sénat où est la démocratie
si chers collègues m'a la pensée mange
comment
merci monsieur le Président alors
puisque on parle du principe d'égalité
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est l'égalité
quand à 43 ans on a les conditions d'un
taux plein l'égalité entre les maires et
les femmes voilà et même voilà donc là
on Déroche à l'égalité cette dérogation
que vous comptez tout à l'heure
une autre égalité ça serait de dire 5%
pour tous ceux qui ont atteint homme ou
femme et dans les femmes mères ou femmes
sans enfant le taux plein à 63 ans mais
je voudrais surtout insister ce que vous
dites monsieur le rapporteur à savoir
que grâce au fait que vous les obligez à
travailler un an de plus elles vont
avoir une meilleure pension mais c'est
méconnettes le mécanisme de la surcotte
quand on dit UNE surcotte de 5%
c'est actuarielle vous devez le savoir
ça veut dire que le patrimoine retraite
c'est-à-dire tout ce qu'elles auront en
termes de retraite de pension de
retraite est strictement égale et neutre
par rapport à l'augmentation de 5%
donnée par la surcote c'est un principe
actuarial neutre ça veut dire que vous
oubliez un petit détail vous dites elles
ont une pension supérieure vous oubliez
qu'elle travaille un an plus et pendant
qu'elle travaille un an plus elle ne
touche pas de pension et le patrimoine
retraite on y reviendra qui est la somme
des pensions dans toute la durée de
retraite est strictement égal dans un
cas comme dans un autre donc vous et les
femmes je serai tenté de dire si à 63
ans avant elle travaillait elle avait
une surcote elle gagne moins avec cette
réforme forcément puisque
comme l'a dit ma collègue pouvait la
voir des 62 ans donc voilà ne dites pas
que vous augmentez les pensions parce
que certes vous les augmentez c'est un
travail jusqu'à 70 ans aussi elle
augmentera sa pension mais elle perdra
en patrimoine retraite merci chers
collègues la parole est au président
Retailleau
rappel le règlement je demande
l'application d'article 38
merci monsieur le président
donc on a été saisi par Monsieur le
Président du Groupe républicain d'une
demande de clôture des explications de
vote sur l'amendement 263
je vous rappelle mes chers collègues je
vous rappelle qu'en application de
l'article 38 alinéa du règlement
la clôture peut être proposée lorsque au
moins deux orateurs d'avis contraire
sont intervenus
conformément à la ligne à 3 du même
article
je vais consulter le Sénat alors
attendez d'abord il faut qu'il y a deux
interventions pardon
il peut y avoir
sur la clôture il peut y avoir une
explication de votre part groupe donc
madame la Présidente rossignol
monsieur le Président retaille vous avez
fait tomber quasiment tous nos
amendements sur l'article 7 vous voulez
vous voulez un débat le plus restreint
possible même vos collègues qui avaient
des amendements c'est la secte Jones des
amendements il se suicide tous
et quand on a un amendement qui porte
sur la question de des bonifications
pour les agents de la fonction publique
ou des majorations de durée d'assurance
pour les femmes du secteur privé même
pas celui-là vous voulez qu'on discute
même pas celui-là un 8 mars mais vous
vous rendez compte ce que vous faites
mais c'est plus c'est plus c'est une
honte
c'est plus ce que vous quand tu permets
c'est plus l'application du règlement
c'est une volonté délibérée de faire
taire l'opposition par tous les moyens y
compris sur les sujets parce que la
personne va dire nous expliquer qu'on
est hors sujet que ces contradictoires
qu'on peut pas en parler et tout à
l'heure sur les amendements de Monsieur
Savary on aura le droit de s'exprimer ou
faire comment on fait on fait un mot au
Président Monsieur le Président
pourriez-vous s'il vous plaît nous dire
si on aura le droit de s'exprimer je
vous remercie beaucoup de votre
attention c'est ça l'idée c'est de nous
humilier en plus mais c'est pas nous
vous humilier c'est les femmes toutes
les femmes
merci
merci chers collègues monsieur Lemoine
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président sur
l'application cet article 38 on entend
beaucoup de récrimination mais
j'aimerais que nous nous souvenions des
conditions dans lesquelles nous nous
sommes fixés tous ensemble cette règle
quelque part de bien vivre ensemble
voilà et bien oui et bien oui
tout cela est issu
d'un rapport qui a été fait par un
membre de la majorité à l'époque UMP un
membre de l'opposition PS c'était en
mars 2015 le bureau du Sénat a adopté ce
rapport dans ce rapport figurait cette
recommandation cette recommandation
était inscrite dans la proposition de
résolution que le président de l'archet
a déposé c'était l'article 10 de cette
proposition de résolution et vous pouvez
aller voir les travaux tant commission
cancéance cet article 10 qui désormais
inscrit l'article 38 dans notre
règlement notre Constitution commune et
bien il n'y a eu aucun amendement le
remettant en cause ni en commission ni
en séance il était adopté sans
modification il n'y a donc pas eu à
l'époque de révolution contre cet
article il y a même eu un assentiment
large et
je dois dire d'ailleurs que ce chantier
sur le règlement il faisait suite à des
premiers réflexions enclenchées par
Jean-Pierre Bel à l'époque et donc tout
cela je crois que nous l'avons assez
largement décidé tous ensemble j'ai
entendu hier dans les débats l'un des
orateurs
sur les bancs de la gauche dire nul ne
peut se prévaloir de sa propre turpitude
je crois que ça s'applique parfaitement
la situation que nous vivons aujourd'hui
merci chers collègues madame Cohen pour
le groupe CRCE
monsieur le Président Retailleau vous
sortez l'article 38 pour nous empêcher
de parler alors on va dire du côté des
bancs LR bah oui mais finalement on est
déjà mercredi donc nous avons
suffisamment des battu ça n'est pas la
conception que nous avons du débat en
plus on a dit que l'article 7 c'était
vraiment le cœur de la réforme et en
plus vous attaquez un amendement le 8
mars qui concerne mais oui mes chers
collègues ça ne vous plaît pas mais
c'est la journée de lutte pour les
droits des femmes vous attaquez un
amendement qui peut effectivement
permettre un débat sur quel est notre
conception de l'égalité professionnelle
quel est notre conception de l'égalité
au niveau des retraites quelle est notre
conception de la progression des
salaires et des carrières féminines vous
n'en voulez pas et en plus moi j'entends
une petite musique quand même que j'ai
dénoncé au nom de mon groupe quand il a
quand nous avons présenté la motion
référendaire j'entends une petite
musique au niveau des bancs LR soutenu
par les bancs du gouvernement qu'est-ce
que vous voulez favoriser vous voulez
pas favoriser les femmes vous voulez
favoriser les maires de famille c'est un
choix qui est vraiment problématique
nous nous voulons l'égalité absolue pour
toutes les femmes et en plus vous n'avez
pas dû lire non plus cet amendement là
de ma collègue parce que il porte sur
les droits familiaux ça devrait vous
intéresser monsieur Retailleau vous qui
prenez la famille comme étant le net
plus ultra papa Maman Les enfants il
faut un petit peu réfléchir
merci chers collègues
alors madame
pour ces monstre pour le groupe c'est
[Musique]
si vous voulez
merci monsieur le Président moi j'invite
les Français à réécouter les trois
interventions qui vous qui ont précédé
et qui ont vous ont fait dire qu'il faut
que le débat s'arrête ces trois
interventions regardez messieurs les
Français le font on était au fond quand
je parlais quand même de patrimoine
retraite et de calcul actuariale j'étais
au fond bon donc j'en déduis que vous ne
voulez pas effectivement qu'on débattre
de l'article 7 et je vous rappelle quand
même que vous avez osé à l'Assemblée
nationale vous vous réclamez des
syndicats pour dire que c'était quand
même très triste de ne pas avoir débattu
de l'article 7 nous y sommes nous avons
jusqu'à dimanche il y avait peut-être
deux jours sur l'article 7 et vous le et
vous ne voulez pas les avoir ce que vous
voulez c'est qu'on discute pas de
l'article 7 parce que c'est dans
l'article 7 qui a les conséquences sur
les travailleurs inég brutal de cette
loi c'est dans l'article 7 que vous
allez créer vous allez prendre 18
milliards sur les travailleurs ce que
vous voulez par contre c'est qu'on parle
beaucoup des autres articles vous savez
ceux qui rendent au travailleur et qui
ont été payés par les travailleurs les
trois milliards donc vous voulez pas
qu'on parle de 18 milliards et de leurs
conséquences sur la pénibilité sur le
travail sur les femmes sur les ouvriers
mais vous voulez mettre tout le débat
jusqu'à dimanche sur les trois petits
milliards de mesure d'atténuation de la
brutalité de cette réforme et
effectivement le le gouvernement ne
communique que sur ces 3 milliards donc
nous on discutera des mesures
d'atténuation de la brutalité de la
réforme mais avant il faut parler de la
brutalité de la réforme c'est l'article
7 et c'est ça que vous voulez pas avoir
pour mieux mettre l'éclairage sur les
mesures d'accompagnement voilà merci
mes chers collègues et il y a encore sur
cette article 7 pas mal d'amendements
donc qui nous permettront quand même
d'aborder je l'espère en tout cas le
fond du sujet et
pour l'instant nous sommes dans
l'application du règlement dans
l'application de l'article 38 dure avec
le manque qui a été demandé par le
groupe les républicains et qui prévoit
strictement les modalités du débat sur
la proposition de clôture à savoir un
orateur par groupe
donc c'est ce qu'on est en train de
faire est-ce qu'il y a encore des
groupes qui demandent à s'exprimer
monsieur Calvet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur des
ministres chers collègues j'ai
l'impression à entendre les propos que
je viens d'entendre justement que
certains confondent le débat et
l'obstruction à quoi a-t-on assisté
depuis à quoi a-t-on assisté depuis
plusieurs jours ce sont des tentatives
d'obstruction ce n'est pas le débat et
le débat devrait avoir lieu si justement
vous étiez respectueux de la capacité de
chacun à pouvoir s'exprimer et le groupe
de l'Union centriste regrette le groupe
de l'Union centrée je regrette justement
que par l'obstruction par la
prolongation des débats par des
amendements qui n'ont aucun sens parce
qu'ils sont similaires il suffit de les
présenter de façon rationnelle et le
débat pour avoir lieu donc on n'a pas
d'autre choix à mon avis que de soutenir
la proposition qui vient d'être faite
pour pouvoir avancer et pouvoir enfin
examiner les vrais sujets à l'ordre du
jour de ce texte
merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
donc je vais soumettre aux voix
l'application de cet article 38
conformément à son alinéa 3 cet article
je vais consulter le Sénat à mallever
qui est pour l'application de l'article
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
l'article 38 donc s'applique et par
conséquent nous
passons alors au vote sur l'amendement
donc avec deux avis défavorables de la
Commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté alors
ensuite nous avons une motion
4766 qui tend à opposé l'exception dire
recevabilité c'est monsieur le
rapporteur
oui bien sûr collègue motion des
recevabilité sur deux
amendements les
2378 et les 432 ce sont
pour les mêmes motifs qu'hier que ces
amendements qui concernent des
catégories particulières d'assurer son
contraire au principe d'égalité consacré
par l'article 6 de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen
c'est le rapporteur alors il y en
aurateur contre la motion des
recevabilité
on est dans la motion des recevabilité
monsieur Assouline
vous l'avez pas
la motion est à l'encontre de deux
amendements de 1378 432
monsieur Assouline
oui bien entendu que c'est de la même
veine et
on a donné les explications de cette
nuit on les a continué tout à l'heure
vous posez une irrecevabilité sur un
contenu rupture de l'égalité
républicaine donc sur le fond or la
commission
et les services d'ailleurs de la séance
n'ont jamais jugé ces amendements
identiques qui étaient déposés avant sur
le fond et sur le contenu comme étant
rupture avec l'égalité républicaine donc
c'est un artifice et ça me permet de
vous redire pour l'article 38 je sais
pas si vous vous rendez compte à quel
point
cette arbitraire non pas l'existence de
cet article mais vous avez argumenté que
cet article était justifié
parce que il y avait des milliers
d'amendements identiques etc et que
c'était de l'obstruction
là maintenant
il a été utilisé sur le seul amendement
pas des milliers le seul amendement qui
était maintenu à la discussion ici et
vous avez empêché par l'article 38 qui
puisse y avoir des explications de vote
différentes et multiples là où vous avez
accepté pendant 50 heures de multiples
interventions sur des amendements qui
étaient parfois secondaire et donc vous
êtes en train de
mais les choses sont claires les choses
sont claires vous avez moi je vais moi
pour moi rien n'est secondaire mais
quand on vient argumenter quand on vient
quand on vient argumenter ici que il y a
des milliers d'amendements un peu trop
similaire pour les retirer là c'est le
seul qui est maintenu et vous mettez
l'article 38 vous empêchez le débat et
vous ne voulez pas discuter de l'article
7 qui n'a pas été débattu à l'Assemblée
nationale merci c'est un scandale merci
chers collègues
quelle est la vie du gouvernement sur
cette motion monsieur le ministre
merci à Monsieur le Président
gouvernement de conteste jamais sur ce
texte comme sur les autres les décisions
de la commission des commissions tant
pour la recevabilité que pour les
recevabilités donc je m'en remets
évidemment au Sénat monsieur Assouline
dit à l'instant qu'un certain nombre
d'amendements pouvaient avoir un
caractère secondaire j'en prends acte et
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire à plusieurs
reprises dans les séances précédentes
qu'il est vrai que parmi les nombreux
amendements qui avaient été déposés
ensuite transporté en sous-amendement et
cela aussi sans juger de la recevabilité
ou de lire recevabilité certains nous
surprenaient à la fois par leur carrière
leur caractère redondants ou encore par
exemple lorsqu'il prévoyait de maintenir
à 62 plutôt que 64 ans l'âge de départ à
la retraite des internes en médecine si
vous connaissez beaucoup d'interdes en
médecine de 62 ou 64 ans cela peut
interroger cela monte juste le caractère
répétitif de l'opération et donc
évidemment je me remets à la vie de la
Commission
merci
Monsieur le Ministre donc j'ai été saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains sur cette motion
d'irres-savilité
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par article
56 du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
résultat du scrutin nombre de votants
344 exprimés 344 pour 251 contre
93 le Sénat a adopté cette motion et
donc les deux amendements sont tirés
sevables donc un moment 2378 est-il
recevable et nous passons localement en
4431 la présente assassy ou non
allez-y chers
collègues aujourd'hui les exploitants
agricoles où les employés sont déjà que
de 20% à être en incapacité dès leur
première année de retraite et 34% des
ouvriers sont déjà contraints dans les
activités de la vie quotidienne dès leur
entrée à la retraite
c'est la preuve s'il en était besoin que
l'allongement de la durée de la vie
n'est pas un argument pour justifier le
report de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite et cela est encore moins vrai
dans les territoires
ultramarins en effet l'espérance de vie
y est six années inférieures en moyenne
à celle des habitants de la métropole la
réforme doit donc tenir compte des
réalités se présente un moment souhaite
l'âge de que l'âge de 64 ans pour un
départ à la retraite ne soit pas pris en
compte pour les habitants de la
Polynésie française nous ne pouvons pas
ajouter de l'inégalité à l'inégalité
toucher à l'âge de départ à la retraite
risque de ne faire que creuser des
écarts les habitants d'outre-mer
méritent mieux que ça avec cet
amendement nous refusons donc
l'application de l'article 7 et de cette
réforme dans sa globalité aux habitants
de Polynésie française
merci de votre attention merci chers
collègues et c'est plusieurs sous
amendements le 4768 qui représente
même les bain
c'est un amendement qui tend à fixer un
délai minimal ah non c'est le 4769
pardon
c'est pareil
minimal à la prise en compte des
critères ou droit au départ à la
retraite par les fonctionnaires
résidents en Polynésie française prévue
par cette amendement il semble
préférable de prévoir un délai de trois
mois avant la prise en compte d'intérêt
ouvrant ce droit en fait comme l'a dit
tout à l'heure ma collègue
raymondeponsemonge l'intérêt sur cet
article 7 c'était de discuter de la
brutalité de ce projet de loi et c'était
de discuter de ce que nous pouvions
effectivement proposer ou amender pour
le rendre moins brutal même si nous nous
souhaitons sa suppression voilà et donc
par les artifices que vous utilisez vous
nous empêchez de discuter de la
brutalité de ce projet de loi et des
conséquences qu'il aura sur des millions
de salariés dans ce pays
merci chers collègues donc le 4767
considère qui a été défendu il va l'être
il va l'être monsieur le président
c'est le Président chers
dans le cadre d'un débat donc vous avez
siamand dégradé la qualité et le niveau
par les procédures que vous avez
choisies dans le règlement en
particulier je trouve personnellement
très très utile que c'est
sous-amendement nous permettent
d'évoquer les différentes catégories
socio-professionnelles de la population
française qui sont mis à mal parce ce
projet de réforme des retraites uniques
et ces particules le cas avec cette
amendement 4767 qui vise à modifier le
critère de prise en compte de départ à
la retraite pour les fonctionnaires qui
résident en Polynésie française et de
nous tenir compte que de leur intérêt
matériel la notion d'intérêt morale qui
apparaît dans le dans le texte étant
pour le moins subjective
chers collègues de 477
sous amendement
c'est le président
[Musique]
c'est le ministre mes chers collègues je
voudrais profiter de ce sous amendement
pour attirer l'attention sur les
fonctionnaires d'État qui résident en
Polynésie française fonctionnaire d'État
ce sont des policiers sont les contrôles
les contrôleurs du trafic aérien ce sont
tout le personnel du Haut-Commissariat
vous le savez c'est fonctionnaires qui
sont en Polynésie française touchent une
bonification de salaire du fait de la
différentielle du coût de la vie entre
la France entre la métropole entre la
grille indiciaire de la de la métropole
et puis bien évidemment le coût réel de
la vie ce coup cette différentielle il
est de 84 de
0,84%. c'est à dire que un fonctionnaire
d'État qui se trouve en Polynésie
française a un salaire de
1,84 par rapport à ce qu'il serait en
métropole pour tenir compte justement de
ce coup de la vie le fonctionnaire
français
paye des cotisations sur 1 84 or
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en 2008 le
ministre de l'époque qui s'appelait Yves
Jégo a considéré que l'indemnité
temporaire de retraite qui permettait
donc au retraites d'être majorée de 94%
contenu du coût de la vie et bien que
c'était qu'il y avait des dérives on
appelait ça des retraites cocotiers
parce que c'est vrai qu'il y avait des
fonctionnaires d'une certaine façon qui
était en France et puis qui sont dit il
y a une bonification d'un 84 si je veux
en outre-mer donc je vais en profiter
donc il a dit et bien tout simplement on
le supprime sur 20 ans on le supprime
sur 20 ans ce qui fait que les
fonctionnaires d'État qui décident de
rester en Polynésie eux vont se trouver
dans une situation où le retraite va
être minorée par rapport au coût de la
vie donc il est important à travers ces
sous amendements de proposer donc des
mesures compensatoires sachant qu'il y a
une négociation qui est en cours avec
les le service du haut-commissaire pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que les
fonctionnaires d'État qui souhaitent
rester en Polynésie puisse avoir les
conditions de vie descente et le 477
défendu
4573 477
monsieur le ministre il faut que nous
prenions le temps quand même de pouvoir
intervenir quoi
cet amendement chers collègues
concerne la Polynésie française
et donc il est question dans ce texte de
pouvoir permettre une retraite des
fonctionnaires prévus par cet amendement
il semble préférable de prévoir un délai
de six mois avant la prise en compte des
intérêts ouvrant à ce droit merci
le 477
merci merci monsieur le Président donc
dans la suite donc tous ces amendements
portent sur la même thématique vous
l'avez compris mais sont importants
Jean-Michel Houlgate a très bien
expliqué quelle était la problématique
et ce délai effectivement de départ à la
retraite pour les fonctionnaires de
l'État résidant en Polynésie française
et justifiant bien sûr des intérêts
requis à notre avis doit être inférieur
à la durée qui a été prévue par les
auteurs de l'amendement et donc c'est
pour ça que on propose et on est ouvert
à une discussion évidemment avec avec la
commission avec leur rapporteur sur
cette question nous on propose de
diminuer ce délai par rapport à ce qu'il
est prévu actuellement et là en
l'occurrence l'amendement que je vous
présente prévoit de réduire ce délai au
lieu de deux années à un délai de neuf
mois je vous remercie
de 4574
c'est durant
oui dans le droit fil des amendements
déposés et présentés par mes collègues
Houlgate et jaumier
cet amendement tend à s'intéresser à la
situation des fonctionnaires de l'État
résidant Polini françaises et évidemment
qui justifierait d'intérêt requis nous
estimons que les auteurs de l'amendement
prévoyant
deux ans pour ce retrait mériterait
d'étudier avec intérêt ce sous
amendement qui lui souhaite diminuer à
un an la période par rapport au
dispositif proposé
[Musique]
même sujet même
inquiétude
comme je l'ai dit à l'instant et comme
mes collègues Houlgate jaumier d'autres
collègues l'ont exposé cet amendement
pour les fonctionnaires de l'État
résident en polynie française et qui
justifie d'intérêt requis propose de
réduire de 10 à 18 mois et non pas deux
ans la durée prévue initialement dans le
dispositif du projet de loi merci chers
collègues monsieur le rapporteur sur un
amendement est sous amendement
oui merci effectivement cet amendement
mettre une distinction entre le régime
hexagonal et le régime des Outre-mer il
y a des propositions tout à fait
intéressantes c'est expliqué
effectivement le dispositif ittr est en
voie d'extinction
2028 monsieur le ministre nous précisera
exactement et c'est vrai que
actuellement c'est une majoration de
pension et qu'il faut le prendre en
compte les
âges les agent anticipés de départ il y
en a déjà énormément cette réforme au
poste beaucoup de temps pour définir
effectivement un article 7 avec un âge
légal qui se décale à 64 ans mais on
passera aussi beaucoup d'articles pour
faire des dérogations et déjà anticipées
donc nous ne souhaitons pas nous ne
souhaitons pas aller à l'encontre de la
philosophie de cette réforme qui n'est
pas celle d'agenticiper mais plutôt un
effort collectif de durée du travail
c'est la raison pour laquelle comme sur
les autres demandes tout à l'heure je
après un avis défavorable et une
précision si vous le permettez Monsieur
le monsieur le
Président les sous amendements
effectivement mérite mérite une étude
approfondie parce que il faut voir
l'impact et en conséquence je ne peux
pas donner
un avis de recevabilité tant que la
Commission ne s'est pas réunie en ce qui
concerne c'est sous amendements donc
avis défavorable sur l'amendement et il
recevabilité sur les sous amendements
merci monsieur le ministre
oui monsieur le Président en réalité sur
ces amendements vous donner des
explications très générales des
différences de coûts de la vie entre les
territoires
ultramarins et métropolitain pour un
sujet très particulier que celui des
fonctionnaires en Polynésie d'abord sur
l'amendement qui vise à différencier
l'effort contributif qui est demandé à
tous les actifs du pays pour un principe
d'équité j'y suis défavorable et ensuite
à travers vos sous amendements vous
abordez en réalité beaucoup de sujets
qui ne sont pas touchés par la réforme
des retraites qu'on est en train de
discuter puisque vous abordez en réalité
deux sujets bien particuliers celui des
intérêts matériels et moraux qui ne sont
absolument pas mis en cause ou toucher
ou impacté par la réforme que nous
sommes en train de discuter et celui de
l'indemnité temporaire de retraite qui
est une indemnité qui est mis en
extinction depuis 2008 qui n'a été
remise en cause par aucun des
gouvernements de toutes les majorités
dont les majorités socialistes dans les
quin qui ont précédé et qui n'a aucun
rapport direct avec la réforme des
retraites sur ces deux sujets ceci dit
pour ne pas répondre à côté j'ai déjà
répondu à une question au gouvernement
sur les intérêts matériels et moraux en
garantissant la bonne application
absolue des matériels hémoraux qui ont
été définis par une jurisprudence du
Conseil d'État extrêmement clairement et
j'ai pris des engagements puisque avec
mon collègue Jean-François caraco je
préside effectivement une commission sur
le sujet particulier de l'indemnité
temporaire de retraite que nous
puissions trouver des mécanismes pour
apporter des réponses les élus
ultramarins qui participent à cette
commission elle a été réunie le 17
février dernier sur l'indemnité
temporaire de retraite le savent d'ici
le PLF de cette année nous aurons trouvé
des solutions pour venir trouver un
mécanisme dérogatoire à l'aide sanction
qui est encore une fois j'insiste sur ce
sujet n'a été remise en cause par aucun
des gouvernements depuis 2008 donc avis
défavorable able sur tous les
amendements et sous amendements merci
monsieur le rapporteur vous dire
préciser quelque chose une petite
précision j'ai fait une erreur j'ai
parlé d'y recevabilités non c'est un
avis personnel défavorable en ce qui
concerne les sous amendements puisqu'ils
n'ont pas été émis étudiés en commission
merci merci monsieur Lurel
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
sujet que je soulève depuis le début de
notre discussion ce texte ne tient aucun
compte des réalités outre-mer là vous
évoquez l'ittr l'indemnité temporaire de
retraite c'est pas seulement la
Polynésie c'est la Nouvelle-Calédonie
c'est Waly se foutouna c'est la Réunion
c'est Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et un
régime un peu spécial pour la ça
n'existe pas en Guadeloupe en Martinique
et en Guyane il y a une mise en
extinction parce qu'il y avait des
fraudes personne n'a contesté un système
frauduleux on a donc réparé résultat les
engagements pris en 2008 commencez en
2019 l'État n'a jamais tenu compte des
compensations dans l'intégration des
primes dans l'assiette des rémunération
et que les économies faites resteraient
dans le territoire résultat des
militaires sont en pauvreté les
fonctionnaires d'états sont en pauvreté
et vous dites ce n'est pas ça impacte et
quand vous avez ici les documents de la
CNAV c'est vrai en Martinique en
Guadeloupe et ailleurs la pension de
retraite en Martinique le régime général
c'est 540 euros c'est des carrières
hachées pour obtenir le minimum
contributif il faut 120 trimestres chez
nous on obtient pas son distrimètre ce
qui fait sa tombe sur les femmes cette
retraite ce projet est kafkin
surréaliste et ignore et vous nous
invoquez l'Iron sauvabilité au nom du
traitement illégal aux différents des
territoires il faut plus de
différenciation pour mieux tenir compte
de réalité c'est fou ce que vous faites
merci euh chers collègues monsieur
Durand
oui monsieur le Président je souscris
aux arguments qui ont été développés par
notre collègue Victoria Lurel juste un
petit point de méthode j'ai bien compris
que que tout ce débat vous agacait
prodigieusement que tout ça allait
beaucoup trop lentement et qu'il fallait
accélérer donc tac vous ne voulez pas de
la main tendue ou de vous offrons pour
vous aider à vous sortir du guêpier dans
lequel vous vous êtes fourré en vous
embarquant dans cette loi aussi mal
fagotée vous ne voulez pas nous nous
laissez vous aider à sortir de
l'impopularité qu'il va falloir assumer
partout dans chaque ville village
préfecture sous-préfecture mais si vous
voulez gagner du temps je pense qu'on
gagnerait quand même à avoir des
dérouleurs qui sont un petit peu
correctement ficelés on a un dérouleur
papier sur lequel n'apparaissent pas les
amendements qu'on vient étudier on a un
tableau électronique qui mentionne des
amendements dans un ordre et on a un
dérouleur numérique qui mentionne un
ordre différent de ce qu'on a là donc un
tout petit peu de méthode nous aidera à
vous aider à aller beaucoup beaucoup
plus vite
merci chers collègues et Madame pour ces
Monges
merci monsieur le Président alors
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez retiré
le recours à lire recevabilité mais
enfin je pense que vous allez peut-être
l'actionner un peu plus tard j'avais
demandé tout à l'heure la parole après
les propos du monsieur de monsieur le
ministre mais vous m'avez pas vu donc
j'en profite pour dire à Monsieur le
Ministre du soft si vous prétendez au
nom de la séparation des pouvoirs ne pas
vous mêler désirsovabilité
décréter notamment par le Sénat je vous
demande d'aller jusqu'au bout et de vous
abstenir de les commenter et surtout en
reprenant les mêmes exemples que
monsieur le rapporteur
en les commentant vous ne respectez pas
la séparation des pouvoirs et beaucoup
plus grave pour vous nous pourrions
croire que vous les avez inspiré
et Monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je défends l'amendement
44 31 monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
usé hier mais on n'a pas eu le temps
d'avoir le débat parce que l'article 38
a été déclenché autour de l'espérance de
vie et
l'amendement que nous déposons vient ici
et de le contredire nous vivons plus
longtemps donc il faut travailler plus
longtemps j'essaie de ne pas caricaturer
vos propos mais c'était à peu près ça
oui mais monsieur le rapporteur pourquoi
on vit plus longtemps
et oui c'est la question il y a la
question la santé publique qui a
beaucoup progressé la question de la
vaccination
la question l'alimentation du progrès
technique la robotisation
notamment au travail qui permet de
gagner de l'espérance de vie et de
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé et
puis il y a eu des lois
plus protectrices pour les travailleurs
et travailleuses au début du siècle on
travaille 10 heures six jours par
semaine bon ben on a atteint un moment
donné les congés payés la journée des
huit heures et puis évidemment les 35
heures le partage du temps de travail
donc si on revient et qu'on est à rebond
de l'histoire à un moment donné on aura
un problème sur la question l'espérance
de vie deuxième argument si nous gagnons
l'espérance de vie pourquoi le donner
qu'au capital
c'est une question on peut le partager
là aussi à un moment donné avec du temps
libéré des contrats du capital et donc
un droit à la retraite pour être utile
autrement et dernière argument sur
lequel vous n'avez jamais répondu en 5
jours oui oui espérance de vie bien sûr
on travaille moins mais on est beaucoup
plus productif que dans les années 80 là
où elle salarié générée 25000 euros de
travail de valeur il en fait 80 000
aujourd'hui et les gains de productivité
sont passés où dans le travail dans les
salaires dans les pensions
j'aimerais la réponse de monsieur le
rapporteur merci beaucoup chers
collègues donc j'ai été saisi de scrutin
public sur ces sous amendements
et sur l'amendement en lui-même
[Musique]
donc je vais soumettre au scrutin public
le sous amendement 4768 avec deux avis
défavorables
le ce que tu as ouvert
vous pouvez rester près des
près de l'écran
demande à voter
le scrutin avec l'eau
nombre de votants 344 exprimé 343 pour
93 contre 250 n'est pas adopté sur
sous-amendement 4767 de ce que tu as
ouvert
votant 344 exprimé 343 pour 93 contre
250 le Sénat n'a pas adopté le 4769
ce que tu as est ouvert
si vous pouvez y aller même guidez
tout vert
plus personnellement à voter
le scrutin est clos
votant 332 exprimé 331 pour 81 contre
250 pas adopté le 477
de ce que tu as ouvert
votant 340 4 exprimés 343 pour 93 contre
250 il n'a pas été adopté 4771 de ce que
tu as ouvert
le
votant 344 exprimés 343 pour 93 contre
250 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
le 4772
le scrutin est ouvert
alors
votant 344 exprimé 343 pour 93 contre
250 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
nous passons 477
de ce que tu as ouvert
le scrutin est clos
votant 344 exprimé 343 pour 93 contre
250 pas adopté 474
le scrutin est ouvert
non on a voté de ce que tu as éclos
votant 344 exprimer 343 pour 93 contre
250 le Sénat n'a pas adopté enfin le
le scrutin est ouvert
votant 344 exprimé 343 pour 93 contre
250 le Sénat n'a pas adopté et je mets
aux voix donc l'amendement 4431 avec
deux avis défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté nous passons à l'amendement
qui représente Madame A poursuppoli
oui monsieur le Président cet amendement
vise à supprimer le recul progressif de
l'âge de départ à la retraite des
générations nés entre 61 et 67 le cœur
battant de votre contre-réforme et au
cœur de la colère tant elle va s'abattre
sur les plus les plus âgés celles et
ceux qui auraient pu espérer d'ici peu
être enfin libéré du travail
1961 62 ans cette année 62 ans et
jusqu'à peu le début du nouvel vie
évidemment
ils ont pu profiter en famille et ces
gens s'engagent aussi parfois dans des
associations et évidemment vous leur
mettez des trimestres en plus vous
infligez ce coup près qui avance de
trois mois en trois mois trois mois de
rien pour vous car nuit après nuit au
Sénat vous nous avez confirmé vos choix
car c'est un choix de société que vous
avez fait et que vous assumez on le voit
bien vous n'irez pas chercher de
recettes vous ne taxerez pas vous n' pas
que vous reste-t-il alors le prélèvement
le plus brutal qu'un gouvernement puisse
faire au peuple vous lui retirez des
belles années de retraite après la
maltraitance des coeurs des corps
excusez-moi au travail et l'angoisse
entretenu on peut dire des cœurs aussi
entre tenu du lendemain vous voilà les
portes voies du désespoir mais vous
allez devoir rendre des comptes demain à
la rue vous allez devoir rendre des
comptes aux salariés de votre de vos
villes respectives la France est dans la
rue la France qui vous a élu à Monsieur
le Ministre
la France qui vous allez élu et ça a été
dit à plusieurs reprises non pas pour la
politique que vous barrez mais
simplement pour faire barrage et vous le
savez vous avez méprisé l'Assemblée
nationale ici aujourd'hui la droite
sénatoriale nous bâillonne elle nous
bâillonne nous sommes victimes de
l'article 38 de motion d'irrecevabilité
jour après jour et oui chers collègues
ça vous fait pas plaisir mais elle c'est
la vérité nous sommes bâillonnés
merci merci quelques précisions si vous
me permettez monsieur le Président et
qui me permettent de répondre sur les
quatre amendements suivants si je
dépasse légèrement mon temps mais je
n'en suis pas sûr simplement c'est un
amendements que ce soit le 4146 et les
quatre suivants reprennent alinéa
paralinéa les durées les durées de
cotisation qui sont augmentées
progressivement par âge de génération en
génération et tant mieux c'est
progressives c'est pas brutalement comme
on peut l'entendre on prend deux ans non
on prend pas deux ans c'est un trimestre
par année de génération ce qui montre
bien qu'il y a une progression alors
effectivement on peut faire des sous
amendements s'opposer à cela et je suis
être pas d'accord avec ça mais on peut
aussi avoir une technique qui consiste à
liner un paralinéa à proposer à
supprimer les 170 69 trimestres pour une
certaine génération
170 pour une autre génération etc
voyez-vous je pense que c'est pas
forcément ça qui va faire avancer le
débat dès l'instant où vous êtes opposé
et nous y sommes favorables par contre
par contre Monsieur gay m'a posé une
question qui me semble-t-il est
intéressante la productivité voilà là ça
mérite un débat la productivité en
France elle est meilleure qu'ailleurs et
bien qu'est-ce que ça veut dire que les
conditions de travail sont pas si
mauvaises que ça ça veut dire que nos
employeurs ça veut dire que nos employés
nos salariés nos travailleurs et ben
quelque part ils travaillent mieux que
dans les pays voisins ça mérite d'être
souligné quand même c'est pas le tableau
misérable que l'on a parfois entendu ces
derniers jours mais se posent monsieur
gay il y a pas que la productivité il y
a également le problème de la population
qui fait un bassin et les heures
travaillées en France 630 heures par an
ramener à l'habitant le pays voisin
madame chillinger vous le connaissez
bien c'est à quelques centaines de
mètres de chez vous
940 heures 630
940 on voit bien qu'il y a des pays qui
ont une conception différente du travail
je pense que ça méritait d'être signalé
et comme nous avons comme nous avons
justement pas suffisamment de production
parce que nous n'avons pas suffisamment
d'heures travaillées pour conforter
notre modèle social il nous appartient
de prendre nos responsabilités c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous demandons cet
effort collectif pour travailler plus
globalement à la fois pour produire
davantage et faire en sorte que nos
jeunes puissent trouver du travail mais
également améliorer l'équilibre de la
réforme des retraites monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le Président l'amendement
présenté par Madame pour ce police
supprime un alinéa de l'article il y en
a trois autres qui suivent qui suivent
les qui suppriment les alinés
impressionnants cela remet en cause la
montée en puissance de la réforme des
Touraine donc le Gouvernement est
défavorable à cet amendement numéro 41
46 comme nous serons des favorables
exactement pour les mêmes raisons pour
les trois suivants je serai plus rapide
madame la sénatrice vous avez vous avez
interpellé en disant la France qui vous
a élu il se trouve que la France qui m'a
élu c'est une circonscription du Nord de
l'Ardèche et c'est plus particulièrement
une commune
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le rapporteur de la réponse on
peut continuer à avoir un débat même si
il sera court mais vous avez pas répondu
sur les gains de productivité vous nous
avez répondu sur la pénibilité et il y a
les métiers difficiles moins difficiles
c'est vrai que le travail à l'usine est
moins pénible aujourd'hui qu'il y a 50
ans mais il peut rester des métiers
extrêmement difficiles y compris à
l'usine sur les chantiers j'ai pas vu
beaucoup d'exosquelette quand j'en
visite mais peut-être demain ou
après-demain ça va exister mais vous
avez pas répondu sur les gains de
productivité
un salarié en 1980 généré 25000 euros de
richesse créée aujourd'hui 80 000 où
sont passés ces gains de productivité ni
dans les salaires ni dans les pensions
de retraite et il y a 10 points donc je
vous réponds 10 points a été volés par
le capital au travail est-ce qu'on est
d'accord ou pas c'est le rapporteur non
mais attendez ça c'est pas c'est pas moi
ou le groupe communiste ou l'ensemble de
la gauche c'est les chiffres fondés non
mais je vous dis ça et donc il faut bien
qu'on ait un débat sur cette question où
est les gains de productivité sur la
productivité horaire on vous a déjà
répondu
l'ouvrier français et un des plus
productifs y compris par rapport à
l'Allemagne et d'ailleurs c'est le
rapporteur je vous le dis là aussi si
votre vision c'est les jobs à 1 euro et
les travailleurs pauvres c'est pas la
nôtre et si votre vision c'est d'avoir
des retraités pauvres comme en Allemagne
ou contrairement à la France où il y a
déjà trop c'est trop 10% de retraité
pauvre mais 21,5 en Allemagne si c'est
ça la société dans laquelle vous voulez
vivre pour nous c'est non je vous le dis
donc c'est le rapporteur je vous demande
de re répondre à la question pour vous
ou sont passés les gains de productivité
et comment mieux les partager je vous
remercie si cher collègue et le
président Patriat demande la parole
c'est le Président je vous remercie je
demande l'application de l'article 38 un
pour rencontre
donc j'ai une demande d'application
d'article 38 à nouveau donc il y a un
orateur pas groupe qui peut s'exprimer
un orateur pas groupement
allez-y
mais est-ce que ça signifie je suis
content bien sûr 38 qu'on va pas pouvoir
commenter ce qui a été dit précédemment
bon alors moi je vais les commenter du
coup voilà alors monsieur le rapporteur
vous avez du mal à voir qui fera 2 ans
de plus bon alors je vous dis les femmes
les femmes à 62 ans pile à 62 ans pile
sont plus nombreuses que les hommes à
liquider leur retraite elles sont 35%
35% des femmes liquides leur retraite à
62 ans pile pour ces 35% de femmes ces
deux enferment
je vous ai déjà signalé mais bon que à
61 ans une personne sur deux plus d'une
personne sur deux n'est pas en emploi
n'est plus en emploi mais
au minimum sociaux au chômage de longue
durée en maladie de longue durée en
inactivité quelquefois sans ressource
cela à 61 ans c'est pour eux ils
pouvaient partir à 62 ans sortir de ces
minimas pour liquider leur retraite pour
eux ces deux ans ferme
c'est ça qu'il faut quand tu quand on
regarde productivité j'ai peut-être pas
le temps mais ils sont quand on voit
l'intensité de travail etc quelques fois
ils sont faits sur une base
d'intensification du travail et de
souffrance au travail donc ils sont pas
tous vertueux les gains de productivité
merci même pour ces moments
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues juste je
défends cet amendement mais juste pour
revenir sur les gains de productivité il
est évident que on l'a déjà dit que que
cette retraite par répartition elle est
aussi elle doit être aussi la
répartition de la richesse produite par
le travail et d'ailleurs je sais plus si
c'est Michel Édouard Leclerc qui a dit à
un moment donné qu'il faudrait accélérer
robots parce que si on pousse à
l'extrême dans l'hypothèse ou où on est
une société totalement automatisée et où
il n'y a plus personne qu'il cotise
parce que personne ne travaille ou n'est
productif c'est une situation absurde
mais mais il faut se poser la question
de savoir justement sur où sont répartis
les gains de productivité je reviens sur
je reviens sur l'amendement en question
pourquoi nous le soutenons tout
simplement parce que cette réforme elle
est brutale elle est brutale elle génère
des frustrations et on l'a vu s'il y a
une s'il y a une mobilisation de cette
ampleur c'est aussi parce que les gens
sont frustrés pourquoi le sont-ils tout
simplement parce que les jantes qui sont
nés en 1961 il se projette et il se
projette d'autant plus qu'il reçoive
régulièrement est-ce qu'on appelle le
relevé individuel de situation et on l'a
tous reçu se relever individuel de
situation et en plus à côté de ce relevé
individuel de situation et bien on
reçoit ce qu'on appelle une Estimation
Indicative Globale et bien avec ça les
gens se projettent ils se disent ben oui
il me reste encore temps de trimestre à
faire et peut-être même que je dois
faire un peu plus compte tenu de
l'ajustement que je fais par rapport à
cette Estimation Indicative Globale
parce que c'est pas suffisant et que je
serai amené à me caler peut-être un peu
plus longtemps mais toujours est-il que
que les gens se projettent et à partir
du moment où de façon brutale on leur
dit ben écoutez vous allez travailler un
trimestre deux ou trois de plus et bien
elle vit évidemment ça génère des
frustrations parce que les gens ont des
projets individuels alors se posent la
question se pose la question du rapport
au travail mais j'aurais eu l'occasion
de leur développer dans d'autres
interventions ici chers collègues
je vais mettre aux voix donc
l'application de l'article 38 qui est
pour l'application d'article 38
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté et donc
nous passons au vote et j'ai demandé de
scrutin public de la part du groupe CCE
sur l'amendement 4146 avec deux avis
défavorables donc il va être procédé ce
que tu as publié que le scrutin est
ouvert
Chine
est ouvert
le scrutin avec
l'eau nombre de votants 344 exprimés 343
pour 93 contre 250 ça n'a pas été adopté
nous passons aux 4146 qui représente
excusez-moi ça m'arrive de me tromper
allez-y merci monsieur le Président
j'étais perdu cet amendement vise à
supprimer la Linéa portant la durée de
cotisation à 170 trimestres dès la
génération de 1963 c'est un peu ce qu'a
dit notre notre rapporteur qui a bien
compris le sens de nos amendements en
2013 nous avons combattu la réforme
Touraine au niveau du groupe communiste
nous considérons naturellement son
accélération comme l'approfondissement
d'une logique mortifère pour les
travailleurs et les travailleuses en
portant la durée de cotisation à 170
trimestres dès la génération 1963 vous
ne prenez pas en compte les réalités du
travail il existe pour de nombreux
Français français une zone grise plus ou
moins longue très inconfortable où les
femmes et les hommes ne sont ni en
emploi ni à la retraite c'était le cas
de près de 16,7% des personnes âgées de
62 ans 2021 dont 3% étaient au chômage
et 13,7% en
et dépendait essentiellement du RSA
d'une pension d'invalidité ou du revenu
de leur conjoint le taux d'emploi des
plus de 60 ans est faible 35,5% contre
46,4 % au sein de l'Union européenne
plus on avance on âge moins on a de
chance d'avoir un emploi surtout si on
n'a pas décroché de titre scolaire là je
constitue avec le sexe le premier motif
déclaré des expériences de
discrimination liées au travail loin
devant l'origine ethnique pointait en
2018 France stratégie allongez donc la
durée de cotisation ne peut que
pénaliser l'ensemble des travailleurs de
la génération de 1963 d'où la
suppression de l'alinéa et monsieur le
Président vous avez vu j'ai pas joué sur
le chrono qui s'était pas déclenché
merci même Cohen monsieur le rapporteur
vous avez donné un avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre aussi il y a deux
avis défavorables donc j'ai saisi d'une
demande de ce que tu as publique sur cet
amendement par le groupe C
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
expliqué en
argumentant sur l'ensemble de ses
amendements que c'était après tout
l'application strict de l'accélération
de la durée de cotisation circuler il y
a rien à voir moi je voudrais vous
parler d'un cas particulier qui montre
en effet la brutalité de cette réforme
je vais vous parler d'un jardinier qui
travaille dans la une ville de
Seine-Maritime qui est dirigé par un
ancien Premier ministre qui est
favorable à la retraite à 67 ans je
pense que vous suivez que vous
identifiez ce jardinier l'exerce depuis
81 il est exposé aux postures pénibles
aux risques chimiques aux vibrations au
gestes répétitifs et me dit-il à
l'accroissement des surfaces à traiter
puisqu'il y a visiblement eu dans cette
ville des réductions d'effectifs
lorsqu'il contact la RH en charge des
retraites il apprend qu'une personne née
en juin 63 peut bénéficier du dispositif
carrière longue mais que lui qui est né
en septembre 63 va devoir travailler 9
mois de plus j'ai rencontré ce jardinier
dans une manifestation parce qu'il
portait une pancarte où était indiquée
42 ans de bonnes conduite 9 mois ferme
et donc les amendements que nous
proposons tout en vous le savez nous
contestons fondamentalement
l'allongement et l'accélération de la
durée de cotisation mais il y a des
situations particulières qui
mériteraient d'être prises en compte
parce que des gens se retrouvent dans
des situations extrêmement difficiles
dans les prochains mois merci chers
collègues donc je mets au vote cet
amendement j'ai demandé de scrutin
public par le groupe CRCE sur cet
amendement 4149 avec deux avis
défavorables
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
nombre de votants 344 exprimer 343 pour
93 contre 250 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
nous passons 4285 qui le défend monsieur
gay
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues comme on
est sur les âges de départ les
trimestres cotisés on voudrait avoir une
confirmation monsieur le ministre si
c'est possible puisqu'on parle d'une
réforme de justice mais pour qu'elle
soit juste faut qu'elle soit
compréhensible par tout et tous et que
on arrive à y voir clair
je commence à travailler à 14 ans
je peux partir à 58 ans mais avec 44
cotisés mais si je travaille à 15 ans
je peux partir au même âge à 58 et avec
43 unités si je commence à travailler à
16 ans je peux partir à 60 ans mais avec
44 à nuitées mais si c'est 17 ans c'est
toujours 60 ans mais avec 43 nuités bref
et ça s'enchaîne comme ça jusqu'à l'âge
de 21 ans et donc on a du mal à voir
comment vous avez construit ce tableau
et qu'est-ce qu'il y a de juste à ce que
lorsqu'on a travaillé commencé à
travailler à 14 c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose qu'à 15 et pourquoi il faut
que je cotise plus pour partir au même
âge je vous remercie monsieur le
Président merci chers collègues monsieur
le rapporteur
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
simplement je vais mettre un avis
défavorable et symbole exemple parce que
actuellement votre personne qui a
travaillé avec 16 ans si elle a qu'à ta
sainte trimestre avant la fin de ses 16
ans elle va partir combien quelle est la
durée de cotisation quelle est la durée
de cotisation d'art + 2 d'art + 2 ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire 45 ans ça
c'est l'application de la loi actuelle
qui a voté cette loi
pardon pas vous vous avez voté cette loi
qu'est-ce qu'il est proposé dans la loi
qui vient que ces personnes qui ont
catalyse un trimestre avant la fin de
leur saison la fin de l'année de leur
saison excusez-moi puisse travailler
moins longtemps et on aura l'occasion de
discuter avec ça c'est l'article 8 parce
qu'effectivement il y a un certain
nombre d'inégalités parce qu'à un mois
près vous tapez la bande suivante et en
conséquence vous prenez effectivement la
2 ans ça mérite un débat voilà ça mérite
un débat on l'aura dans l'article 8
vivement qu'on y soit l'article 8
merci monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
c'est la vie défavorable que j'ai déjà
exprimé j'ajoute à ce que dit monsieur
le rapporteur que pour pouvoir partir
dans le cadre des dispositifs carrière
longue il suffit pas d'avoir quatre ou
cinq trimestres cotisés avant le dernier
jour de l'année civile de vos saisons de
vos 18 ans demain ou de vos 20 ans il
faut avoir les 4 à 5 trimestres cotisées
avant la borne d'âge il faut atteindre
l'âge d'ouverture des droites telles que
prévu par la loi c'est à dire 58 ans si
vous avez commencé avant 16 ans dans la
loi aujourd'hui et il faut par ailleurs
avoir atteint la durée de cotisation
requise en l'état de la loi la Dar + 2
intégralement cotisée sans tenir compte
des trimestres qui ne serait que valider
et cotisés ce qui explique qu'entre les
principes de départ au titre des
carrières longues et la bonification
effective il y a un écart parce que bien
souvent dans la carrière des uns et des
autres tous les tous les trimestres
arrivaient à l'âge légal ne sont pas des
trimestres cotisées mais une partie
peuvent être validées le service
militaire par exemple et ce qui explique
les décalages ce qui rend assez
inopérant pardon le dire comme ça les
comparaisons de Data ou d'anniversaire à
anniversaire puisqu'en réalité ça
renvoie au parcours de vie de chacun
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc j'ai été
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe CRCE sur cet amendement
4285 avec deux avis défavorables il va
être procédé au scrutin public le
scrutin
est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
nombre de votants 344 exprimés 343 pour
93 contre 250 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
nous passons 4286 qui le défend
allez-y madame
merci monsieur le Président à l'instant
nous avons échangé en vue de la
suppression de l'article 7 qui est le
cœur de votre contreforme sociale à
défaut d'avoir pu supprimer tout cet
article nous nous attacherons donc à
retirer le du texte ce qui nous semble
le plus problématique l'allongement de
l'âge légal de départ en retraite les
alinéa cités dans notre amendement sont
précisément ce qui décaleront demain
l'âge légal de 62 à 64 ans pour pouvoir
partir en retraite et partant de là
allongeront pour tous les Français les
carrières de deux ans on a eu l'occasion
d'en discuter longuement mais selon les
chiffres de la DARES publiés en janvier
2023 pour l'année 2021 le constat est
affligent malgré six ans au pouvoir
votre gouvernement n'a pas réussi à
enrayer le chômage des 50 Saco et plus
aujourd'hui la frontière des 60 ans se
matérialise par une chute d'activité de
68% à 59 ans vers 43% à 61 ans pour
atteindre 15% à 64 ans en reculant l'âge
les légales de la retraite vous créez
une trappe de pauvreté dont les Français
de plus de 55 ans qui perdent leur
emploi ne pourront pas s'en sortir la
réforme de l'indemnisation invalidité
joue elle aussi contre les travailleurs
je ne citerai qu'un seul exemple celui
d'un couple de boulanger de mon
département elle a un cancer lui a des
problèmes cardiaques après des années à
maintenir coûte que coûte une activité
ils ont fini par vendre leur atelier or
avec les nouveaux modes de calcul des
pensions d'invalidité il ne touche plus
que 900 euros à deux
âgé de 58 et 60 ans comment vont-ils
vivre ces prochaines années
qu'auront-ils comme retraite comme tous
les artisans et commerçants de notre
pays leur outil de travail et le
patrimoine de toute une vie il pensait
l'utiliser fièrement pour l'avenir de
leur enfant les études des
petits-enfants et bien non comme de
nombreux travailleurs qui ont réussi à
mettre un peu de côté votre réforme va
les dévaliser et pendant ce temps-là les
fraudeurs aux cotisations sociales les
év Adés fiscaux les profiteurs de la
crise dorment sur leurs deux oreilles
reculez
monsieur le rapporteur avis défavorable
l'amendement nous aurons l'occasion à
l'article 8 de parler des invalidité
très bien monsieur le ministre mais ma
vie même avis donc monsieur gay
Marinal madame limon merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues une des questions là aussi que
sur lequel vous n'avez pas répondu on
vient d'avoir le débat enfin on n'a pas
eu de réponse sur quel productivité on
essaie de continuer à prendre argument
par argument parce que un débat c'est ça
on pose une question vous répondez on
ressort un contre argument on épuise le
truc voilà et puis à un moment donné il
y en a un qui marque un point bon pour
l'instant on n'a pas été au bout quoi
bon on a marqué beaucoup de poèmes bon
mais c'est vous qui maîtrisez le match
sur comme ça mais nous on respecte le
règlement à la lettre une des questions
une des questions sur le rapporteur
c'est que vous allez décaler la borne de
l'âge légal de 62 à 64 ans et donc c'est
une question vous allez le mettre et le
placer sur l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé et une des questions dans le sur
lesquelles il faut parler et à partir de
la réalité du vécu des gens c'est pas
grave à chaque fois qu'on parle du
véhicule des gens j'entends des ah mais
on est bien là pour parler du vécu des
gens et donc quand on déplace la borne
de 62 à 64 ans qui est la borne de
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé ça
veut dire qu'ensemble enfin nous non
mais vous faites le choix de placer la
Baume pour la moitié des gens ils
partiront pas à la retraite en bonne
santé et c'est quand même une question
pour nous nous pensons qu'après une dure
vie de labeur et le travail source
d'émancipation et les insociable mais
aussi de souffrance physique et
psychique on pense qu'il faut vivre une
retraite pendant des années au moins en
bonne santé parce que si on place la
borne au moment de l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé on connaît un certain nombre
de personnes notamment de métier où les
gens ils ne profitent pas la retraite
parce que on profite pas quand on tombe
malade de suite et qu'après pendant deux
ans on est entre les rendez-vous
médicaux et l'hôpital donc il faut bien
qu'on ait ce débat là je vous remercie
monsieur le Président merci chers
collègues le président rénal
oui moi je reconnais que ces évocations
de personnes touchées par les réformes
sont difficiles à entendre on le
comprend bien mais en même temps c'est
bien ça la réalité et ce débat est
passionnant de ce point de vue là il
faut effectivement sortir ici de la
théorie il faut voir ce que nous faisons
et comment ça se traduit pour les uns
pour les autres et nous devons tous me
semble-t-il l'accepter et plutôt écouter
ces témoignages et vous faire votre
propre opinion alors je voudrais revenir
sur un propos du rapporteur tout à
l'heure qui m'a un peu surpris m'a fait
un lien un peu direct un peu trop direct
entre la productivité et l'idée que si
les Français avaient une forte
productivité c'était qu'il était pas si
mal au travail c'était un drôle de un
drôle de lien tout de même je voudrais
j'ai recherché depuis quelques éléments
mais que je retrouvais facilement avec
ça heureusement on trouve tout alors
l'enquête euroshound sur les conditions
de travail en Europe qui a été réalisée
qui est réalisé d'ailleurs chaque année
et auprès de 71 000 personnes en 2021
mais la France en queue de peloton parmi
les 36 pays sous revus presque 40% des
actifs en emploi chez nous se trouve
dans un emploi détendu où les exigences
sont plus élevés que les ressources
permettant de répondre à celle-ci et mes
chers collègues monsieur le rapporteur
parce que vous avez sans doute pas lu
cette étude on est au niveau sur ces
sujets là on est au niveau de l'Albanie
de la Slovaquie de la Pologne je dis pas
que ce sont pas des exemples je me
prononce pas mais je le mets sur le
débat quand même et je pense qu'il faut
arrêter de faire ce lien un peu rapide
entre productivité et plaisir d'être au
travail
merci monsieur le Président Madame
poncemonge
merci monsieur le Président alors j'ai
bien entendu
la fébrilité de monsieur le rapporteur
qu'on a à l'article 8 très certainement
pour parler de quelques mesures que vous
proposez mais nous sommes à l'article 7
et l'article 7 il dit que la quasi
majorité des départs anticipés sont des
départs
rendus possible par la mobilisation du
C2P c'est à dire par par la pénibilité
et de moins en moins par les carrières
longues c'est-à-dire quand on a commencé
ou super long comme vous le voulez et
dans l'article enfin par l'article 7 ce
départ anticipé il est retardé de deux
ans là aussi ces deux enfermes monsieur
le rapporteur effectivement si vous avez
quelques améliorations il faut pas trop
sauter trop vite à l'article 8 pour dire
les petites mesures d'accompagnement que
vous allez faire mais déjà constater
acter que les départs anticipés pour
pénibilité par deux ans plus tard quant
à la validité permanente si on a des
propositions si vous avez des
propositions pour l'instant nous sommes
d'accord rien n'a changé ils partent à
62 ans toujours dans la loi c'est pour
ça monsieur le ministre que je vous dis
que les 3 milliards que vous mettez en
mesure d'accompagnement n'ont pas lieu
d'être puisque c'est le maintien d'un
dispositif mais par contre Monsieur le
Ministre puisque vous avez fait tout
votre équilibre financier en comptant
indument ces 3 milliards sans alors que
c'est maintenu je vous propose de passer
l'invalidité permanente à 60 ans auquel
cas vous pouvez remettre les 3 milliards
100 en mesure d'accompagnement merci
Monsieur Houlgate
les différents amendements qui nous ont
été proposés portent sur les personnes
qui sont nées entre 1961 et 1965 ça
tombe bien je veux dire dans la majorité
des gens qui sont ici ça nous concerne
c'est un peu notre génération cette
génération 61-65 d'une certaine façon
dans le monde du travail a connu je
dirais des évolutions c'était la fin des
30 glorieuses ça a été les nombreuses
restructurations et ça a été les
évolutions parmi les nombreuses
restructurations moi je vous invite pour
ceux qui aiment la littérature à lire
les livres de Nicolas Mathieu notamment
leurs enfants après eux économara
qu'est-ce que dit Nicolas Mathieu il
fait le descriptif de ses enfants un peu
perdus de la génération de ceux qui ont
perdu leur travail avec les
restructurations en Lorraine et il
montre combien sont leurs difficultés et
combien justement ils ont dû à travers
le travail essayer de surmonter ces
difficultés ces difficultés elles sont
aussi conséquente à des mutations donc
le développement de l'automatisation de
la numérisation et ainsi de suite on a
commencé à parler dans le monde du
travail de risque psychosociaux et il
faut souligner que c'est la loi du 17
janvier 2002 Martine Aubry qui a
introduit la notion de santé mentale
dans le code du travail ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que d'une certaine
façon c'est une génération je veux pas
dire que c'est une génération qui a été
sacrifiée mais c'est une génération qui
a vécu une profonde mutation du monde du
travail et qui en était elle-même
profondément marquée et peut-être
peut-être un peu meurtri donc cette
génération prononce en garde moi je dans
les manifestations et on l'a retrouvé
d'ailleurs dans un article de
Ouest-France ou quelqu'un disait
peut-être à travers ce mal au travail
que sur lequel on a beaucoup pris les
choses en considération mais il a dit
moi ma vie professionnelle ça a été un
marathon et bien j'ai l'impression que
on a reculé la ligne d'arrivée de ce
marathon alors on peut le déplorer il y
a des choses qui ont été faites mais
faisons attention à cette génération
sacrifiée 61 65 sirium
il a il a déjà été beaucoup dit il a
déjà été beaucoup dit le problème de la
génération avec cette accélération qui
s'attendait à partir en retraite et qui
voit brutalement le mur reculé mais je
voudrais insister sur les faits sur le
niveau des pensions en accélérant les
délais de la réforme Touraine plus en
allant jaune deux ans là je les gale on
va avoir un effet sur le niveau de
pension extrêmement préoccupant puisque
dans ces simulations la pension moyenne
net passerait de 61,2% du salaire moyen
en 2021 à
51,6 en 2050 soit
-15,7%. puis ensuite seulement à 45,4%
en 2070 soit moins
25,8%. c'est une chute brutale du niveau
de vie des retraités qui jusqu'à présent
est assez proche du niveau moyen des
revenus de les revenus des Français bien
que depuis deux trois ans c'est déjà
baissé et là on va atteindre des choses
terribles puisque on va retrouver des
retraités pauvres je vous donne les
chiffres c'est au lieu d'être à 5 ans à
égalité ce ratio ne serait donc plus de
100% mais de 89% en 2050
94% en 2070 donc de toute façon ce qui
est vrai c'est pourquoi nous avons mené
des amendements sur les recettes c'est
que dans le système actuel si on veut
rééquilibrer les retraites il y aura
quand même besoin de recettes
merci chers collègues le président
malgré demande la parole merci monsieur
le Président je sur cet amendement je
demande l'application de l'article 38
1 qui avait intervenir contre ma mère
contre
sur l'application
vous devez intervenir pour votre groupe
contre
la demande qui vient d'être formulée je
pense que ce soir et dans les heures qui
viennent il va falloir s'attendre à
avoir ces demandes récurrentes pour nous
empêcher pour nous empêcher d'un
véritablement dans un débat de fond un
débat sérieux toutes les interventions
qui se sont tenues jusqu'à maintenant
sont des interventions sérieuses fondées
argumenté et donc je ne vois pas vous
avez le droit effectivement d'activer au
titre du Règlement du Sénat de demander
d'activer certains cycles 38 mais vous
imaginez bien que nous y sommes
totalement opposés et que là encore une
fois encore une fois vous bafouez
véritablement le rôle du Sénat c'est une
atteinte à la démocratie que d'autres et
que à l'extérieur parce qu'on nous
regarde à l'extérieur on nous regarde on
nous écoute à l'extérieur et quand on
verra que lorsqu'on s'engage sur ces
débats et sur ses amendements qui ont
été déposés absolument justifier parce
qu'ils sont même sur le fond même et la
déclinaison très précise à
concrétisation de ce recul d'âge pour
beaucoup de nos concitoyens qui vont
voir les conséquences dès cette année
dès l'année prochaine et non pas dans
les années à venir sur les conséquences
de cette réforme brutale de propositions
de recul d'âge merci monsieur benaroche
merci monsieur le Président en fait
depuis un moment je j'essaye de
comprendre à quel moment les articles 38
vont être demandés j'ai pensé à des tas
de critères je me suis dit finalement
c'est assez logique je pourrais être
défenseur de de et demander moi-même
d'ailleurs l'application d'article 38 à
partir du moment où nous avons affaire à
des débats sans aucune tenue sans aucune
valeur ou aucun argument n'est développé
où chacun d'entre nous n'apprend rien ou
ceux qui nous regardent sur Public Sénat
ou sur les chaînes de télé n'apprenne
rien de la loi sur les retraites or ce
n'est pas le cas donc je me dis c'est
pas le critère puisqu'en fait moi-même
j'apprends beaucoup de choses en
écoutant mes collègues de tout bord
d'ailleurs lorsqu'ils veulent bien
donner à certains ordres d'arguments et
non pas être sur des postures donc je me
suis dit si c'est pas ça qui fait que
l'article 38 est utilisé c'est sûrement
parce qu'il y a une autre raison
alors la raison c'est quoi la raison en
fait me semble-t-il mais je me trompe
peut-être il faudrait faire une étude
statistique je m'excuse vous avez
demandé l'article 38 j'ai le droit
d'exprimer ce que je pense vous n'êtes
pas obligé de le couper voilà donc je me
suis dit c'est une autre raison quelle
est cette raison et en faisant une
petite étude sur les deux fois où vous
l'avez utilisé par rapport au fond vous
ne l'avez pas utilisé on verra si c'est
confirmé par l'effet dans le futur il me
semble en fait que vous l'utilisez mais
peut-être me trompe à partir du moment
où vous estimez que le débat devient
suffisamment intéressant et appuie à
certains lampes d'arguments auxquels
vous ne souhaitez pas répondre puisque
vous ne voulez pas prolonger le débat
vous avez les réponses vraisemblablement
je suis persuadé que vous avez des
réponses pour argumenter contre les
arguments qui ont été proposés mais vous
ne pouvez pas les donner puisque c'est
votre règle ne pourra pas les données
vous décidez d'écourter le débat parce
qu'il est argumenté et vous les
courtiers effectivement en posant
l'article 38 si je me trompe
dites-le-moi chers amis mais je pense
que je suis dans le vrai si chers
collègues madame Lindemann
chers collègues on pouvait pas dire que
le débat qui était engagé sur ce sujet
était pas un débat intéressant parce
qu'on était au coeur du débat sur le
niveau des pensions
du débat sur le l'effet de seuil de
changement qui est toujours un problème
politique pour tout le monde quand il y
a une réforme et là bâclé le discussion
va créer les effets de réflexion alors
vous savez qu'est-ce que ça révèle chers
collègues quand on est embarrassé quand
on sait qu'on est en décalage avec le
peuple et ben on essaie de faire ça vite
fait ni vu ni connu à la sauvette alors
comme Monsieur Macron quand les amis de
Lorraine nous explique il faut aller
plus vite on a l'habitude chers
collègues ils passent son temps à nous
dire qu'il y a trop de parlementaires
que le Parlement ça va trop vite qu'on
fait toujours des procédures d'urgence à
la limite je dirais c'est leur culture
de contournement du parle mais vous la
majorité sénatoriale elle est a priori
ça ne devrait pas être votre culture
alors que vous soyez un peu agacé parce
que nous avons la force de nos arguments
j'appelle le comprendre mais vous
devriez comprendre que nos concitoyens
attendent de vous des explications des
réponses à nos arguments de faire
entretenir le débat mais vous avez peur
de l'opinion publique vous ne vous
sentez pas fort pour les renforcer et sa
justifie votre votre stratégie décourtez
le débat merci chers collègues donc je
vais mettre aux voix l'application de
l'article 38 qui a été demandé qui est
pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient donc l'article 38
s'applique et donc nous allons passer au
vote j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe CRCE sur
cet amendement 4286 avec deux avis
défavorables
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin iclo nombre de votants
alors on ouvre le scrutin
ce que tu as été à nouveau ouvert
c'est un clou
donc le scrutin est clos
nombre de votants 344 exprimés 343 pour
93 contre 250 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
nous passons à trois amendements
identiques le 1895 la présidente de la
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues l'article l351 14-1 du code de
la sécurité sociale créé par la réforme
des retraites de 2003 prévoit un
mécanisme de rachat d'année d'étude pour
les assurer salariés depuis 2003 les
assurés peuvent donc ainsi racheter
jusqu'à 12 trimestres d'assurance
vieillesse au titre des années d'études
supérieures le tarif du rachat qui fait
selon l'âge et le niveau de revenu et
déterminé selon un principe de
neutralité actuelle c'est-à-dire qu'il
pèse intégralement sur son bénéficiaire
si ce versement est pris en compte dans
le calcul d'une retraite classique les
trimestres ainsi rachetés ne sont pas
retenus dans le cadre de dispositifs de
retraite anticipée pour carrière longue
ou pour les travailleurs handicapés il
nous faut donc corriger ce point tout
comme le mécanisme mis en place par la
réforme des retraites de 2014 qui a
établi un tarif préférentiel de rachat
trimestre pour certains assurés
notamment les apprentis au titre des
périodes d'apprentissage du 1er juillet
1972 au 31 décembre 2013 car il cotisait
sur une assiette forfaitaire trop faible
pour leur permettre de valider une durée
d'assurance vieillesse égale à celle de
leur contrat nous souhaiterions donc les
assurés ne soient pas pénalisés par
l'absence de prise en compte de ces
versements dans le cadre d'un départ
anticipé pour carrière longue ou en tant
que travailleur handicapé aussi nous
proposons que ces versements soient
désormais pris en compte tant dans la
période cotisée que pour apprécier la
condition de début d'activité au titre
du dispositif de retraite pour carrière
longue je vous remercie
le 1909 identique monsieur lévrier
merci monsieur le Président comme cela
était indiqué précédemment cet
amendement vise à permettre la prise en
compte dans le cadre d'un départ
anticipé pour carrière longue ou en tant
que travailleur handicapé les trimestres
d'apprentissage effectués avant 2014 et
racheté à tarif réduit c'est pour nous
une question de justice sociale que
d'assurer que tous les citoyens ayant eu
un statut d'apprenti puisse obtenir
l'avantage leur trimestre
d'apprentissage et parce que je crois
profondément à l'apprentissage que je
crois profondément à ces jeunes qui
choisissent cette filière et tout
particulièrement à ceux qui ont subi des
accidents de la vie c'est pourquoi je
tiens à vous présenter cet amendement
déjà porté à l'Assemblée nationale et
qu'il me tient particulièrement à coeur
je vous remercie et le 3403 identique
madame pourceymonge
oui monsieur le président
en préalable je tiens exprimer mon
émotion
pour défendre un des 17 amendements qui
ont survécu
après le sous amendement je ne parle
même pas de ceux qui n'avaient même pas
survécu
à l'irrevabilité en commission dans un
premier temps mais j'avais 157
amendements qui avaient trouvé qui était
paraît-il recevable et il s'en est plus
que 17 donc c'est un grand moment
d'émotion
donc bon je peux pas mettre cette
digression parce que c'est un petit peu
la même chose donc l'article 27 de la
loi du 20 janvier 2014 qui a ouvert la
possibilité pour certaines catégories
d'assurer par dérogations aux principes
de neutralité actuarielle de bénéficier
d'une diminution du coût de leur
versement c'est notamment le cas vous
l'avez dit pour les apprentis dont le
nombre a récemment explosé comme vous le
savez tous fin 2022 la DARES sont
dénombrées 980 000 soit près d'un
million il faut bien préciser qu'il faut
l'essentiel de l'amélioration des
statistiques de l'emploi avec les
radiations mais c'est un autre mécanisme
donc il faut donc pouvoir garantir à ses
assurés qui ne soient pas pénalisés par
l'absence de prise en compte des
versements évoqués
dans le cas et notamment dans le cadre
effectivement d'un départ anticipés pour
carrière longue ou en tant que
travailleur handicapé le contraire
serait injuste d'autant que précisément
leur carrière commence très tôt en
conséquence notre amendement vise à ce
que ces derniers soient désormais prise
en compte dans la période cotisée les
rendant par ce fait éligibles au titre
du dispositif de retraite pour carrière
longue il s'agit donc enfin d'une mesure
de justice et d'une mesure de bon sens
[Musique]
et d'avoir effectivement
posé ses amendements parce que il y
avait
une anomalie quand même que ces
trimestres
justement d'apprentis soit pas pris en
compte à la fois dans la durée mais
aussi dans le calcul derrière de la
carrière et notamment pour les carrières
longues
véritablement la carrière longue c'est
vers les apprentis que c'est décidé ceux
qui commencent de bonheur c'est pas pour
ceux qui sont me semble-t-il plus loin
il se rapporte d'un dispositif commun
vraiment de 16-18 ans c'est 15 même 15
18 ans c'est vraiment là qu'on a besoin
de prendre en compte les apprentis et
donc
ça montre bien la différence mes chers
collègues de calcul entre la carrière
longue on prend que les trimestres
cotisés ou réputés cotisés dans le
calcul des 43 ans qu'il y aura à faire
mais 43 ans sur une carrière normale il
faut qu'on en parle c'est pas une
carrière longue c'est la carrière
normale maintenant et les 43 ans pour
les autres qui s'appliquent après à
partir de 20 ans ou à l'intérieur de ces
43 ans vous avez les trimestres cotisés
réputés cotisées assimilés et les
majorations de pension quand il s'agit
de mère de famille donc on voit bien
qu'il y a une différence de traitement
mais il était nécessaire merci monsieur
le ministre d'avoir aussi la même
réflexion il était nécessaire de le
prendre en compte je vous réponds bien
volontiers parce que ça ça répond de
l'article 7 les questions précédentes
Raymondes c'est bon je ne le sait bien
quand même le C2P c'est pas certain que
là et Madame Liman elle sait bien aussi
que les petites pensions c'est l'article
10 donc les réponses on les fera en
fonction des articles si on arrive à
clarifier ce débat comme ça je pense
qu'on peut éviter de sortir l'article 38
non donc on clarifie le débat et on fait
en sorte que les questions qui se posent
elles se posent au bon moment si vous en
êtes d'accord bien entendu donc à vie
très favorable en tout cas
merci monsieur le Président il s'agit
d'amendement identique un amendement
déposé par la députée Christine le
labour qui n'a pas pu être examiné à
l'Assemblée et comme ce qui a été dit
par les différents intervenants cela va
permettre d'intégrer dans les périodes
prises en compte pour l'éligibilité au
départ anticipé au titre des carrières
longues les trimestres effectués en
apprentissage et tout particulièrement
ceux qui ont fait l'objet d'un rachat de
trimestre au tarif préférentiel qui sont
prévus pour les rachats trimestre donc
c'est une mesure du de justice et le
gouvernement il est favorable et
Monsieur le GATT
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues puisque on en
est au stade des questions moi j'ai une
question à poser à René Paul Savary
puisqu'on parle beaucoup des des
apprentis et à juste titre donc les
apprentis sont concernés mais il y a
d'autres catégories et notamment il y a
une catégorie moi qui me touche
particulière ment c'est ceux qu'on
appelle les aides familiaux et ces aides
familiaux on les retrouve dans deux
secteurs dans le secteur agricole il y a
eu énormément d'aide familiaux agricoles
dans ce domaine et puis bien évidemment
dans le domaine du commerce également où
on a vu bien souvent des enfants de
commerçants qui d'une certaine façon
avant de reprendre l'activité parentale
était dans des conditions qui sont
souvent un peu floues qui qui apportait
donc une aide donc à la tenue à la tenue
du commerce donc est-ce que ces aides
familiaux à partir du moment où comment
dirais-je leur activité professionnelle
serait reconnue en termes de trimestre
on la possibilité puisque souvent ils
n'ont pas été couverts par une
cotisation de pouvoir procéder à le
rachat parce que c'est le terme qu'on
emploie au rachat de de ces trimestres
je trouve ses amendements intéressants
même si bon il est quand même question
de rachat de trimestre et on sait que
les rachats de trimestres coûtent cher
mais bon
c'est une fenêtre me semble-t-il
intéressante monsieur le rapporteur je
vous prends au mot
monsieur le rapporteur je vous prends au
moins
non monsieur monsieur monsieur le
rapporteur
je vous prends au mot effectivement sur
des amendements de fond voilà on peut
discuter et donc on discute c'est à dire
que si même on débat pardon on débat et
donc et donc comme je vous prends moi je
vous le dis sur des amendements comme
celui-là et comme celui de tout à
l'heure mon amendement sur l'histoire
des 5% de surcote je ne comprends
décidément pas pourquoi l'article 38 a
été déployé parce qu'on était vraiment
sur le fond là aussi sur le sujet
oui
donc je mets au bois ces trois
amendements identiques
notre groupe votre âmement déposé par
notre collègue
lévriers nous pensons que c'est une
avancée et puisque souvent nous explique
qu'il faut augmenter qu'en augmentant
les cotisations on allait nuire à
l'emploi et à la compositivité des
entreprises comme si la baisse des
cotisations était le fin du fin de la
création d'emplois je vous rappellerai
que dans les échos de juin 2022 il nous
est bien expliqué que dans l'année 2022
il est a priori et ça a été confirmé
d'ailleurs après que les deux tiers des
200 000 emplois créés dit dans le privé
l'ont été en apprentissage et donc c'est
moins la baisse des cotisations que le
soutien donné à des emplois pour former
des jeunes générations qui aura résolu
ou en tout cas baisser le niveau du
chômage nous nous soutenons en tout cas
cet amendement
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
mes chers collègues simplement
pour m'étonner un peu de des procédés
ici maintenant sur l'utilisation de
l'article 38 là aussi
il suffira de revoir finalement ce qui
se passe dans cet assemblée pour se
rendre compte que ça fait un moment
qu'on est pour pas dire depuis toujours
sur le fond mais
monsieur Savary vous avez une pratique
amusante sympathique je me souviens que
depuis l'article 2 à l'article 2 vous
nous dites mais
avançons avançons parce que on va
traiter les sujets et on va les traiter
notamment à l'article 7 en disant tout
ça faut aller vite faut aller vite il
faut aller à l'article 7 et maintenant
que nous sommes à l'article 7 vous nous
dites pour aller vite il faut aller à
l'article 8 bon voilà il y a une espèce
de de côté comme ça systématique nous
renvoyons nous renvoyant en permanence
au sujet d'après quoi voilà donc je
voulais je voulais vous dire je voulais
vous dire que ce procédé il faudrait
maintenant l'arrêter je vous rappelle
d'ailleurs que vous avez fait vous êtes
fait un honneur d'ouvrir très largement
plus qu'à l'Assemblée le temps de
discussion alors il faut quand même
maintenant l'utiliser ah voilà c'est pas
la peine c'est pas la peine d'avoir
annoncé on travaille jusqu'à dimanche
soir pour menacer les trop vite et se
retrouver je sais pas désemparé vendredi
par exemple donc tenez
votre parole il faut aller au dimanche
soir on doit aller au dimanche soir
allons-y calmement et enfin dernier mot
je voudrais quand même féliciter notre
collègue pensez manger je crois qu'on
peut le faire parce que c'est le premier
amendement de cette partie de
l'hémicycle qui est bientôt je le crois
accepter on peut applaudir
merci chers collègues
le président bar
monsieur le Président je ne me connais
pas la force d'un certain nombre
d'arguments qui viennent de nous être
présentés
je suis moi-même un passionné de
l'apprentissage et je considère qu'il
est essentiel dans notre pays que les
jeunes
adoptent cette disposition d'esprit
essentiel qui consiste à choisir ses
études en vue du métier et à faire
l'apprentissage du métier en situation
de travail pour autant il me semble que
cet amendement dans la rédaction est
approximative
n'a pas été suffisamment étudié et en ce
qui me concerne je voterai donc contre
cet amendement et je suggère à tous mes
collègues de s'y opposer je m'y poserai
en tout cas fermement jusqu'à ce qu'on
est plus faire avancer la discussion
pour améliorer le contenu de ce genre
d'initiative
bon je vais je vais mettre au bois à
monsieur le ministre voulait
merci monsieur le Président juste un mot
pour répondre aux interrogations de
Madame Lubin et si il me le permet de
répondre et de dire un mot aux questions
d'abord pour dire que Madame Liban ne
m'écoute pas d'abord dire à Madame Lubin
que le dispositif pour ce qui concerne
l'apprentissage fait que les trimestres
travaillent en apprentissage sont
comptés comme cotisés depuis 2013 parce
que la rémunération des apprentis a
atteint un niveau qui permet de les
compter il a été prévu dans la loi 2013
applicable à partir 2014 la possibilité
d'un rachat rachat autour de 1500 euros
le trimestre ça peut paraître beaucoup
comme ça mais cela deux caractéristiques
c'est une somme fixe pendant toute la
carrière alors que tous les rachats de
trimestres sont fondés sur une somme qui
tient compte d'une méthode actuelle et
qui peuvent atteindre 5 à 6000 euros si
on les rachète à la toute fin de la
carrière donc je dis que ça avantageux
parce que la somme fixe de 1500 euros
est valable tout au long de la carrière
par contre la prise en compte de ces
trimestres rachetés étaient prévus pour
ce qui concerne la durée de cotisation
requise pour avoir accès à une retraite
à taux plein sans décote mais pas pour
l'éligibilité au départ au titre des
carrières longues et donc ce que nous
faisons avec cet amendement ce qui est
proposé par les parlementaires en tout
cas c'est de permettre l'accès aux
dispositif de départ de carrière longue
sur la base de citron racheté sachant
que nous ne chantons nous ne changeons
rien aux conditions de rachat de 2014 et
pour dire à Monsieur le questemba que
que je tiens rassuré monsieur le
kesterba il s'agit vraiment d'intégrer
donc ces trimestres rachetés alors
qu'ils ont été réalisés dans le cas d'un
contrat d'apprentissage qui n'était pas
suffisamment rémunéré pour être
considéré comme cotisé dans le cadre des
trimestres retenus pour l'éligibilité au
départ entier pour les carrières longues
vous interrogez sur sa rédaction je peux
vous assurer monsieur le Kester que la
rédaction proposée par le parlementaires
reçoit la probation complète des
services du gouvernement
merci
la parole est au président malgré
merci monsieur le Président il a eu sur
cet amendement plusieurs orateurs qui
l'ont défendu un orateur qui s'est
exprimé contre le ministre et les
rapporteurs se sont longuement exprimés
sur cette abandon je demande donc
l'application de l'article 38 merci
je suis saisi donc sur cette amendement
de l'application d'articles 38 le
président Gontard
merci
merci Monsieur le merci monsieur le
Président je suis je suis heureux que
que le président Malleray est enfin
trouvé le livre vert mais franchement
franchement
l'article 48 ok vous avez fait une
découverte depuis depuis hier soir ça
c'est rigolo 5 minutes mais quand même
on est en train de débattre sur des
amendements RDSE RDPI écologiste on est
en train de d'échanger
même il me semble que Monsieur
rapporteur a dit que c'était intéressant
on a eu des vrais des vrais échanges
même le président bat aussi a intervenu
il me semble pour dire d'ailleurs les
doutes qui pouvaient avoir sur cet
amendement donc il me semble quand même
que ces échanges qu'on a eu ils sont
plus utiles ils sont plus qui est
intéressant donc moi je suis quand même
déjà sur l'usage de l'article 38 comme
vous le faites depuis hier soir qui est
totalement scandaleux mais le faire de
cette manière là sur des amendements sur
lequel on est dans une discussion
qu'est-ce qui change par rapport
à notre habitude et notre habitude qu'on
a ici de débattre de manière sereine
qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est-ce qui vous
énerve aujourd'hui pourquoi vous ne
voulez plus débattre qu'est-ce qui vous
qu'est-ce qui vous gêne dans cet article
7 quelle est cette obstruction quasi
continuelle ça y est Monsieur monsieur
manuré a trouvé son livre vert et
maintenant il va nous faire des articles
38 après article 38 c'est quand même
enfin comme donc franchement je pense
que vous pourriez encore retirer qu'on
puisse débattre et sereinement pouvoir
voter pour pouvoir voter ses amendements
qui me semble important en plus on l'a
dit c'était peut-être le seul amendement
de cette partie là de l'hémicy qui
pouvait être qui peut venir peut-être
quelque peu enrichir ce texte quand même
et en plus c'était un amendement de
Raymonde pourcemonge qui quand même n'a
pas ménagé sa peine depuis le début de
ce
depuis de début de ce débat
merci monsieur jaumier
merci
monsieur le président
malgré
nous avons tous constaté que sur ces
trois amendements il y a eu des échanges
qui étaient il me semble terminé le
ministre s'est exprimé et je crois sauf
erreur qu'il n'y avait plus de demandes
de parole
votre déclenchement de l'article 38
amène chacun des groupes de l'opposition
maintenant à s'exprimer pendant le temps
qu'il aurait dévolu pour vous faire
remarquer que vous êtes en train de
tourner en ridicule l'application de cet
article vous êtes en train de le tourner
en ridicule
il n'y avait vous ne pouvez pas vous ne
pouvez pas arguer de la moindre
obstruction à l'occasion de c'est la
discussion de ces amendements à
l'occasion de la discussion de ces
amendements donc si vous êtes parti pour
appliquer l'article 38 sur chaque
amendement sur chaque amendement il va y
avoir des prises de parole de nos trois
groupes pour pointer le fait que
pour pointer le fait que vous êtes dans
une application indiscriminée qui vise à
faire obstacle à la conduite des débats
moi j'appelle mais vraiment je vous
appelle à ne pas voter l'application de
l'article 38 sur cette sésamandement là
et vous verrez qu'il n'y aura pas une
pluie d'intervention que en gros le
débat était puisé il y aura peut-être un
collègue ou je ne sais pas ou deux qui
s'exprimera je n'en sais rien non nous
avons eu un débat apaisé et intéressant
le ministre a apporté des éléments qui
étaient intéressants et si vous ne
voulez pas de ce type de discussion
alors effectivement nous allons passer
quatre jours à des interventions
purement sur la forme qui vont là
n'avoir aucun intérêt vous avez la
responsabilité vous avez la majorité
vous avez des armes du règlement vous
avez aussi la responsabilité que la
conduite des débats soit apaisée merci
chers collègues madame Brulat
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président
frappé que notre collègue m'a lu ré qui
donne des leçons de démocratie à la
terre entière
soit choqué que chacun puisse défendre
ici quelques amendements je trouve que
le débat qui vient de s'engager était
d'un apport au débat global parce que
c'est la première fois à ma connaissance
que nous a que nous abordons ce sujet de
l'apprentissage moi j'ai été
particulièrement intéressé d'entendre
l'argumentation du de Philippe Bas et je
pense que ce sujet mérite d'être
approfondi
la deuxième chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que
l'Assemblée nationale détient désormais
le record de du nombre de 49,3 qui ont
été appliqués je crois qu'on en est déjà
11 est-ce que le Sénat veut s'engager
dans une concurrence
où il activeait l'article 38 bien
davantage encore j'ai eu l'occasion de
le dire tout à l'heure j'ai entendu
pique pendre ici et parfois pour de très
bonnes raisons de la manière dont
c'était déroulé le débat à l'Assemblée
nationale
il faudrait pas me semble-t-il que ce
qui ressorte c'est que l'image du Sénat
donne la même mais si si mes chers
collègues si mes chers collègues c'est
l'image qui va rester parce que vous
savez nos concitoyens ils ne sont pas
férus comme vous de des articles du
règlement intérieur du Sénat ils sont
férus de débats démocratiques sur sur un
sujet qui engage leur vie et donc vos
procédures et vos manœuvres ils n'en ont
que faire ils veulent que nous
argumentions et que nous défendions les
uns et les autres comme il est légitime
de le faire nos options nos projets de
société sur des sujets aussi précis et
utiles que l'apprentissage merci chers
collègues même un président de Delattre
[Applaudissements]
oui merci monsieur le Président je ne
prendrais pas la parole sur l'article 38
mais je voulais saluer la vie favorable
de la commission et sortir un peu de ce
débat stérile parce que je pense que le
RDSE n'est pas dans une manœuvre
d'obstruction mais nous avons rendu peu
d'amendements et quand ils le sont c'est
vraiment pour améliorer nos articles
nous sommes regardés par beaucoup de
personnes concernées par cet article et
cet amendement spécifiquement nous avons
été sensibilités par beaucoup
d'associations de personnes handicapées
qui sont concernées par ces amendements
donc j'aimerais que cet amendement ne
soit pas pris en otage
mais vraiment que nous puissions en âme
et conscience le voter parce que c'est
une mesure juste et au Sénat nous savons
peser sur ces mesures justes donc chers
collègues je vous demanderai
effectivement de pouvoir suivre
la vie favorable de la commission merci
merci chers collègues monsieur le
Président Retailleau
ce qu'a proposé Bernard jaumier c'était
très intéressant il a proposé que une
sorte d'antan pour qu'on aurait on
aurait pu se concentrer avec l'accord de
l'ensemble des groupes
sur ce qui constitue le cœur de la
réforme sur ce qui constitue l'essentiel
de nos intérêts c'est ce que le
président Gérard Rachid vous a proposé
ce matin juste avant la conférence des
présidents messieurs les présidents de
groupes de gauche et vous avez refusé
parce que vous voulez faire de
l'obstruction parce que vous voulez que
le Parlement de votre part
l'obstruction c'est un parlement qui se
fait Hara-Kiri l'obstruction c'est la
négation du parlementarisme
l'obstruction c'est une prise en otage
d'une minorité sur l'ensemble de
l'institution
si
et nous vous obligez à recourir à
l'article 38 si chacun est raisonnable
si chacun discute au fond des articles
sans volonté d'obstruction alors oui
chacun pourra jouer le jeu mais la balle
est de votre camp écoutez
j'ai 11 amendements vous voulez que vous
voulez que je les lisser 11 amendements
4769 70 71 des amendements d'obstruction
et j'en ai d'autres par dizaines et par
centaines c'est ce que les Français
doivent savoir donc le 38 il est fait
pour
neutraliser une manœuvre d'obstruction
la manœuvre d'obstruction c'est la
négation du rôle du Parlement
merci chers collègues
la parole est au président patriarche
et sans interrompre et en essayant de
laisser l'opposition s'exprimer le plus
longtemps possible avec beaucoup de
patience et avec beaucoup d'acuités je
le dis mais par contre il y a une chose
que je supporte pas mes chers collègues
c'est l'hypocrisie
parce que l'hypocrisie ça consiste à
dire ici on veut débattre de
l'apprentissage moi l'apprentissage
c'est un sujet qui me passionne les
sujets qu'on aborde maintenant sont
passionnant qu'on puisse en débattre oui
mais le problème pour vous c'est pas de
débattre le débat c'est le faux prétexte
parce que ce matin j'étais en conférence
des présidents et j'ai entendu les trois
présidents des groupes d'opposition dire
clairement qu'il ne voulait pas qu'on
vote le texte au beau et ils l'ont dit
et ils l'ont dit donc nous faire croire
aujourd'hui qu'on veut débattre plus
qu'on veut toujours débattre plus tout
ça en fin de compte le débat plus il est
uniquement pour atteindre l'objectif qui
sont donnés celui de ne pas voter ce
texte se dessaisir se dessaisir de
pouvoir de voter la loi trouve sa
parfaitement hypocrite et je le dénonce
merci chers collègues
donc je vais mettre aux voix
l'application de l'article 38 qui est
pour l'application d'article 38
qui est contre
qui s'abstient donc l'article 38 est
adopté donc va être appliqué et donc
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe
écologiste sur les amendements
identiques
1895-1909 et 3403 avec deux avis
favorables il va être procédé donc au
scrutin public le scrutin est ouvert
est-ce que tu as éclos
nombre de votants
344 exprimés 344 pour 344 contre 0 le
Sénat a adopté
[Applaudissements]
alors des amendements identiques
et en discussion commune trois
amendements identiques tout d'abord le 9
monsieur Cairn
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous savons tous que l'activité des
sportifs de haut niveau impose un
engagement personnel très important qui
lui est susceptible donc de décaler
l'entrée dans la vie professionnelle
aussi pour compenser cette situation un
dispositif de validation de trimestre a
été mis en place en 2012 pour les
sportifs qui sont inscrits sur la liste
des sportifs de haut niveau le nombre de
trimestres maximal qui peut ainsi être
acquis et limiter à 16 soit 4 ans ce qui
correspond à une Olympiades avec cet
amendement on vise à porter ce nombre
maximal de validation de trimestre à 32
soit 2 Olympiades et par ailleurs il
ouvre également la possibilité sportive
de haut niveau de racheter des périodes
antérieures à 2012 ou des périodes
postérieure à 2012
Candice identique monsieur Savin
merci monsieur le Président je pense que
c'est amendement devrait aussi faire
l'unanimité dans cette hémicycle et
comme le rappeler Claude Kerne donc cet
objectif c'est de permettre aux sportifs
au niveau inscrit sur les listes et
ministérielles de pouvoir donc étendre
ce dispositif à 32 trimestres nous en
réjouissons il sera ainsi plus adapté la
durée moyenne des carrières sportives
c'est un moment propose également bien
sûr d'ouvrir pour ses athlètes le rachat
de trimestre et c'est une bonne avance
par contre Monsieur le Ministre tous les
athlètes ne sont pas concernés par cette
mesure et certains qui ont jeune femme
et hommes qui ont brillé les couleurs de
la France sur les différents terrains
lors des compétitions olympiques et des
championnats du monde ne bénéficie pas
de ce dispositif je parle de tous ceux
qui étaient avant la réforme de 2012
donc aujourd'hui nous avons toute une
série d'athlètes qui se retrouvent en
dans une situation ne bénéficient pas
donc parce n'ayant pas cotisé et de
trimestre validée donc ne bénéfice pas
ce dispositif j'avais déposé un
amendement pour corriger cette situation
pour ces athlètes inscrits sur les
listes de haut niveau avant 2012 mon
amendement a été déclaré irrecevable par
le Sénat par le rapporteur mais monsieur
le ministre le droit à pension prévu au
7 de l'article l331 51-2 du code de la
sécurité sociale est-il ouvert à toute
personne inscrite sur la liste
ministérielle des sportifs de niveau
avant 2012 sinon pouvez-vous ce soir
vous engagez à ce que le gouvernement
corrige est injustice je rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui 10% des personnes
éligibles font appel à ce dispositif
donc c'était pas quelque chose qui va
impecter fortement les finances de
l'État mais c'est une question de
justice par rapport à celle et ceux qui
font briller les couleurs de la France
sur tous les terrains du monde et qui
aujourd'hui pour certains sont en grande
difficulté financière merci merci chers
collègues amendements identique le 2298
madame boulet ferronnier
merci monsieur le Président donc tout a
été dit par mes collègues sur
l'important des sportifs sur ce qu'ils
incarnent est-ce que le fait qu'il
représente la France à l'international
sauf que moi mon amendement vise à
permettre au pouvoir réglementaire de
porter ce nom de maximale de validation
trimestre à 64 soit 16 ans conformément
carrière sportive de nos meilleurs
compétiteurs comme je viens de le dire
je vous remercie merci trois amendements
identiques également discussion communes
le 141 qui le défend
non monsieur dessus alors allez-y le
2475 oui merci monsieur le Président oui
c'est un amendement toujours sur les
sportifs de haut niveau et c'est
vraiment une catégorie très large ça ne
concerne pas évidemment que les
millionnaires du ballon en réalité ça on
parle de Françaises et de Français qui
réalisent des performances
significatives dans des épreuves de
toutes les catégories parfois des sports
qu'on ne regarde qu'une fois tous les
quatre ans aux Jeux olympiques mais qui
pour eux correspondent à des années et
des années d'effort et d'entraînement
fait pour l'ambition d'une nation
sportive pour l'ambition de la France
qui parfois même est exprimée de façon
un peu abrupte par le président mais
donc pour Félix pour récompenser cet
engagement personnel on contrairement à
mes collègues sont laisse la liberté
d'augmenter ce nombre de trimestres
qu'on peut être pris en compte par un
décret mais j'ai la même question que
mon collègue Savin sur l'extension du
dispositif avant 2012 merci
Monsieur bruit le 141
merci président cet amendement identique
porté par notre collègue Dominique
Théophile et l'ensemble de notre groupe
répond à une forte attente d'une demande
sportive depuis 2012 un dispositif de
validation de trimestre financé par le
Ministère des Sports a été mis en place
pour les sportifs inscrits sur la liste
des sportifs de haut niveau le nombre de
trimestres maximales pouvant être ainsi
acquis est limité à 16 soit 4 ans
correspondant à une olympiade cet
amendement vise à porter ce nombre
maximum de validation de trimestre à 32
soit deux Olympiades il ouvre par
ailleurs la possibilité aux sportives de
haut niveau de racheter des périodes
antérieures à 2012 ou des périodes
postérieures à 2012 France terre de jeux
olympique cet amendement vise à
s'assurer que les sportifs ne sont rien
pénalisés pour leur engagement je vous
remercie les chers collègues de 292
président Kenner
monsieur ministre
le président Macron en novembre dernier
avait dit qu'il ne fallait pas politiser
le sport je ne suis pas du tout d'accord
avec cette approche parce que je pense
que le sport est évidemment politique
et que quand un pays comme le nôtre
organise de très grands événements
sportifs il rentre dans la catégorie des
nations qui au travers d'un soft power
montre leur force et pas que sur les
sujets à caractère militaire comme
malheureusement nous pouvons le voir
aujourd'hui en 2021 les Jeux Olympiques
de Tokyo ont permis aux sportifs
français de ramener plus de 30 médailles
et le président de la République a juste
titre a dit qu'il n'était pas assez
qu'il faudrait faire mieux pourquoi
parce qu'il en va effectivement de
l'image de la France et parce que ces
événements sportifs constituent un
élément de notre rayonnement
international bref mes chers collègues
le sport est politique voilà au meilleur
sens du terme et d'ailleurs il n'y a
qu'un bon sens dans la matière bien loin
de l'image du sportif professionnel
multimillionnaire ça existe ça existe
dans certains sports le foot voir le
rugby le basket etc ça peut exister dans
les pays anglo-saxons dans les pays
anglo-saxons il y a des millionnaires
rugbyman bien loin donc de l'image de ce
sportif multimillionnaire les sportifs
de haut niveau sur des catégories de
sport très différents qui s'appelait du
surf au honotting et bien leur
engagement est extraordinaire et il n'y
a pas de reconnaissance ils vivent
parfois de salaire de misère et bien
nous vous proposons qu'il y ait une
validation complémentaire cet amendement
propose de doubler cette possibilité de
validation de trimestre et de passer à
32 trimestres 8 ans soit deux Olympiades
si mais ce rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président voilà des
amendements intéressants sur lequel on
peut se réunir
sans passer non plus une éternité dans
les débats si tout le monde est d'accord
voyez-vous il faudrait mieux qu'on aille
vers
les débats où il y a des confrontations
bien c'est une augmentation du nombre de
trimestres pouvant être validés au titre
de l'inscription en tant que sportif de
haut niveau et il est proposé de passer
à 16 à 32 trimestres mais avec l'accord
du gouvernement parce que sinon nous ne
serions pas couverts donc cette durée
est fixée par décret il y a un
engagement de Monsieur le mini mais il
va nous le confirmer sinon on ne serait
plus d'accord de passer à 32 par décret
ok donc vous pouvez proposer plus
moi c'est le décret
donc tous les amendements qui poussent
plus non décret et puis ensuite donc
avis favorable bien sûr
l'ensemble des 6 amendements mais il y a
une réserve monsieur ça va qui vous a
pas échappé et je vois bien que mais il
n'empêche que vous proposez la
possibilité d'abaisser par décret le
montant des cotisations qui s'aperce qui
s'avère superfétatoire voilà le principe
là aussi c'est le décret qui fixe qui
diminue ou qui augmente d'accord donc
pour être conforme à tout cela outre la
partie normative il y a la partie
réglementaire et en conséquence
si tout le monde se soumet aux
amendements sans la modification avec la
modification ce sera un avis favorable
sur l'ensemble des amendements donc il
faut retirer effectivement
la partie qui concerne le montant des
cotisations puisqu'elle sera fixée par
décret monsieur le ministre nous dira ce
qu'il pense faire comme décret j'ai été
clair
merci
merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président de la vie du
gouvernement et favorable sur les
amendements numéro 9 141
2475 et 292 il sera favorable à
l'amendement numéro 10 de Monsieur Savin
sous réserve de la modification proposé
par Monsieur rapporteur qui consiste
pour la bonne clarté de tout cela en la
suppression du petit B de l'amendement
que vous aviez que vous avez rédigé et
déposé ça c'est la première chose
deuxième chose engagement été pris par
ma collègue mini des sports que le degré
permette de porter à 32 trimestres la
durée possible à la place des 16
trimestres actuellement enfin monsieur
le sénateur ça va vous proposez que le
niveau des cotisations puisse être vu à
la baisse nous travaillons sur un
dispositif différent puisque il s'agit
d'un dispositif qui relèvera directement
du ministère des Sports notre objectif
est de permettre sportif d'avoir pour la
période qui vient
de l'écran de trimestre et pour la
période avant 2012 une possibilité de
rachat le plus simple parce que nous
sommes toujours dans ce cadre là c'est
une rachat avec les rails du droit
commun si le ministère des Sports
souhaite accompagner de manière plus
marquée dans le cas de la rédaction du
décret nous y sommes ouverts mais ça
fait l'objet d'un travail avec eux sur
les paramètres permettant ministère
d'accompagner plus particulièrement cela
donc favorable sous la réserve de la
modification
merci monsieur le Président donc bien
sûr à la demande du rapporteur je retire
le petit B donc après l'alinéa 12 et
donc j'entends bien la proposition de
Monsieur le Ministre de travailler sur
aussi des sportifs de haut niveau avant
2012 ce qui permet aussi de répondre à
une vraie demande de cannelle à la
rappeler aujourd'hui nous avons des
sportifs de haut niveau qui ont fait
briller les couleurs de la France qui
ont des salaires de 1000 euros de de
salaire et c'est pas convenable donc
j'espère que votre déclaration permettra
à la ministre des sports mais aussi à la
ministre des budgets de pouvoir trouver
une solution qui puisse répondre à cette
attente donc je retire bien sûr je suis
d'accord avec la proposition du
rapporteur merci monsieur usuas
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
monsieur le ministre mais mes chers
collègues je trouve que c'est un
dispositif vraiment très intéressant et
c'est une façon en effet de pouvoir
renforcer la nation sportive en
permettant par la voix réglementaire de
proposer aux sportifs de racheter comme
ça des trimestres j'ai seulement un gros
regret très gros regret c'est que bien
évidemment il existe des sportifs de
niveau 1000 existent aussi des
chercheurs de haut niveau et moi
j'aurais aimé que ce dispositif puisse
s'appliquer aussi au doctorant j'ai
proposé un amendement pour le faire
malheureusement il ne sera pas discuté
mais il y a 30% des doctorants
aujourd'hui qui n'ont pas de contrat
doctoral c'est à dire qu'ils offrent ils
offrent trois ans de leur temps à l'état
sans aucune reconnaissance de la Nation
j'espère vivement monsieur le ministre
que vous pourriez corriger cette
inégalité merci monsieur le président
merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur
merci monsieur le Président ce sont
d'excellents amendements en effet
merci monsieur le Président je voulais
juste me réjouir du fait que sur tous
ces bancs il y ait un soutien pour une
disposition qui me semble déroger de
manière pertinente au principe d'égalité
devant la loi démontrant ainsi le
caractère totalement idéologique de
votre décision de déclarer et recevable
de tous nos autres amendements qui
proposaient des choses similaires sous
amendements oui c'est vrai excusez-moi
les amendements étaient évidemment
recevables et il est sous amendements ne
l'était pas alors qu'il proposait la
même chose je vous remercie de me le
faire remarquer et donc des montrant que
cette décision de faire tomber des
milliers de sous amendements qui
proposaient des dégradations similaires
étaient parfaitement idéologique et
injustifiée
merci chers collègues je vais mettre aux
voix ces 6 amendements j'ai été saisi
d'une demande scrutin public par le
groupe écologiste et les groupes
socialistes sur tous ces amendements qui
sont devenus identiques le 10 ayant été
modifié je vous rappelle que il y a deux
avis favorables le scrutin est ouvert
votant 344 exprimé 338 pour 324 contre
14 le Sénat a adopté
nous poursuivons avec cinq amendements
dont quatre identiques le 77 la
présidente de Lattre
oui monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues l'allongement de la durée des
études constitue une grande avancée un
atout pour notre société mais il a pour
conséquence indirecte un déficit des
années de cotisation c'est la raison
pour laquelle la réforme des retraites
de 2003 a mis en place un dispositif de
rachat de trimestre titre des périodes
études supérieures mais le tarif élevé
de ce rachat déterminé sur le principe
de la neutralité actuarielle le rendait
difficile d'accès de fait il était
surtout effectué par des assurés proches
de la retraite la réforme des retraites
de 2014 a alors permis aux jeunes actifs
de racheter jusqu'à 4 trimestres
d'assurance au titre des années d'études
à un tarif préférentiel pendant les dix
années qui suivent la fin de leurs
études pour autant force de reconnaître
que ce dispositif s'adresse à des jeunes
dont tous ne sont pas encore préoccupés
par la constitution de la retraite ou
pleinement du fait des possibilités de
dans ces conditions il nous paraît
légitime de pouvoir leur donner un peu
plus de temps pour racheter ces
trimestres d'études à un tarif aidé ce
qui leur permettra aussi de s'installer
dans la vie professionnelle aussi cet
amendement propose que les trimestres
puissent faire l'objet d'un rachat
jusqu'à un âge qui serait fixé par
décret sans qu'il ne soit inférieur à 30
ans je vous remercie de votre attention
merci mes chers collègues
le 1914 identique monsieur iacovelli
oui monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues comme cela a été dit
précédemment le rachat Atari réduit de
trimestre titre des périodes d'études
supérieures permet aux assurer de
valider plus facilement leur durée
d'assurance pour atteindre le taux plein
plus rapidement et ainsi améliorer
considérablement leur pension de
retraite cependant aujourd'hui les
conditions d'accès au rachat sont
beaucoup trop restrictives ce dispositif
s'adresse en effet à des jeunes actifs
plus intéressés par l'élaboration et la
conduite de leur vie professionnelle
présente plutôt que la constitution de
leur retraite future souvenez-vous chers
collègues à l'âge de 33 35 ans vous
n'étiez pas à cette époque tout à fait
disposé et dans des possibilités de
rachat de ces trimestres c'est un moment
propose donc d'étendre l'âge pour
réaliser ce rachat sans qu'il ne soit
inférieur à 30 ans laissons le temps à
chacun de vivre ce moment charnière
après les études laissons le temps de
définir son projet de carrière avant de
penser à la retraite dont nous du temps
à la flexibilité à chacun sans que cela
ne porte
10 sur le long terme à nos concitoyens
également
identique le 2021 il est défendu
défendu
le 3404
identique madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président alors
effectivement la loi du 21 août 2003
portant réforme des retraites a créé un
dispositif de rachat tarif réduit de
trimestre au titre des périodes d'études
supérieures ce dispositif permet aux
assurés qui ont fait des études
supérieures quelque fois longues avant
d'entamer leur carrière de valider plus
facilement leur durée d'assurance pour
atteindre le taux plein afin d'améliorer
leur tension de retraite mais cette
possibilité de rachat semble trop
limitée dans ces contraintes temporelles
les assurés ont 10 ans après la fin de
leur dernière année d'étude pour acheter
l'équivalent de 4 trimestres ce délai
nous semble trop contraignant à la
sortie de leurs études les jeunes actifs
sont plus directement préoccupés par
leur insertion dans un monde du travail
qui est de plus en plus difficile les
jeunes ont vu leur taux de chômage
multipliés par trois et demi en 40 ans
et lorsqu'il parviennent enfin à
travailler ce sont des emplois précaires
pour beaucoup d'entre eux
selon France stratégie 35% des 15 29 ans
ont un contrat temporaire CDD intérim
apprentissage la préoccupation première
vous le comprendrez mes chers collègues
de ces jeunes c'est donc d'abord le
travail l'insertion et la décohabitation
qui se fait de plus en plus tardivement
pour toutes ces raisons il nous semble
logique d'assouplir les conditions
d'accès au rachat au titre des études
supérieures pour que les rachats
prennent en compte la nouvelle réalité
de la station des jeunes sur le marché
de l'emploi de plus en plus difficile de
plus en plus tardive et c'est précisons
ce que nous proposons ce que le groupe
écologiste propose avec cet amendement
et chers collègues de 1986 monsieur
Cardon
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
moment visa étant de la durée
laquelle les étudiants et les anciens
étudiants peuvent effectuer une demande
de rachat de leur trimestre
lors de leurs études supérieures à un
tarif réduit actuellement c'est fixé à
10 ans après la fin des études la durée
actuelle ne coïncide pas forcément avec
la capacité financière ça a été dit par
Monsieur yakovelli mais encore faut-il
agir pour ces jeunes justement pour
éviter ce genre de situation
c'est triste de Noël donc ça va plutôt
un amendement de repli en réalité et
quand on y revoit les difficultés sur
les pré-étudiants sur le l'achat de la
première voiture sur la capacité à
s'installer aussi qu'on devient joli
actif c'est une réelle difficulté et
donc là l'idée c'est de décaler c'est
pourquoi on propose de décaler à 15 ans
pour permettre aux anciens étudiants de
racheter les leurs trimestres plus
tardivement pour que leur parcure de vie
soit plus facile et puis rassurez-vous
c'est amendement ne coûte pas un euro
j'en profite pour vous dire après
effectivement que le la majorité
présidentielle a refusé le repas 1 euro
à l'Assemblée nationale j'espère que la
grosse coalition et l'air gouvernement
et les centriste vont voter la PPL
centriste sur le repas 1 euro j'espère
tu serais j'espère que les centristes
vont pas se faire blouser dans cette
affaire
merci chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur
merci tout se passait bien jusque là
j'ai cru que nous avions retrouvé la
sérénité il n'empêche que sera soit
trimestre et quand même quelque chose
d'important et
monsieur Cardon vous proposez 15 ans
pour acheter les trimestres actuellement
c'est 10 ans mais le gouvernement
propose qu'on puisse les racheter jusque
là je de 30 ans jusque là j'ai plus un
délai donc je pense que il vaut mieux se
mettre en accord avec la proposition du
gouvernement qui est une amélioration
par rapport à ce que nous se connaissons
aujourd'hui
monsieur le ministre vous proposez et
que ce soit dans une limite pour fixer
de cet âge par décret et il ne peut pas
dépasser l'âge de 30 ans nous
souhaiterions avoir des précisions quant
à la
la volonté de fixer un âge un peu plus
précis dans le décret sinon bien sûr
avis favorable et je vous demande
monsieur Cardon de retirer votre
amendement ou avis défavorable merci
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président le
gouvernement donne un avis favorable au
77 19 14 20 21 34 04 comme l'a dit
Monsieur l'importer nous allons faire en
sorte par un décret et c'est un
engagement qui est ainsi pris que l'âge
de rachat des trimestres de stage soit
porté puisque aujourd'hui nous changeons
finalement les règles mais soit portée à
au minimum 30 ans et donc nous mettrons
dans le décret la possibilité de rachat
jusqu'à 30 ans c'est un changement de
méthode d'une certaine manière puisque
un peu plus loin dans la discussion nous
aurons à pardonner moi j'ai fait une
confusion là c'est l'âge de rachat des
trimestres d'études et justement un peu
plus tard dans la discussion nous aurons
des amendements pour faciliter les
rachats de trimestre de stage et donc
notre objectif est que les trimestres
d'études puissent être rachetés jusqu'à
30 ans et tout à l'heure nous le verrons
que les trimestres de stage puisse être
racheter jusqu'à 25 ans alors
qu'aujourd'hui ils peuvent être achetés
dans les deux ans qui suivent le stage
alors même que certains sont encore
étudiants deux ans après la réalisation
du stage donc c'est une demande de
retrait au 29 86 puisque monsieur le
sénateur vous travaillez sur une durée
alors que nous avons fixé une borne
d'âge au moins 30 ans
merci Monsieur Brouillet
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il n'est
jamais bon de garder des ressentis en
soi donc je voulais intervenir pour vous
dire les choses suivantes je suis
coaporteur spécial de la commission
rapporteur spécial la commission des
finances sur la mission travail emploi
je souhaitais m'exprimer sur l'article
1895 rectifiés notre collègue de Lattre
même article de notre collègue lévrier
et de ma collègue qu'on s'est Monge
j'avais dans cette hémicycle souligné
d'ailleurs l'importance pour notre pays
de la réussite de l'apprentissage et ça
n'est pas tous les jours que je
complimente le gouvernement même s'il
concerne aujourd'hui plus des bacs + 4
que des bacs - 3 j'avais donc sollicité
la parole à cet article et lever le bras
avant que le mon collègue de sénateur
bat ne s'exprima et avant que monsieur
malurey ne sollicite lui-même la parole
pour demander l'article 38 vous ne
m'avez donc pas vu monsieur le Président
et l'activation de l'article 38 m'a
empêché d'intervenir ce n'est pas très
grave au fond puisque c'est amendement a
été voté à l'unanimité y compris par le
sénateur bas qui avait pourtant expliqué
à quel point il était mal écrit et
devait être rejeté je m'interroge encore
d'ailleurs si cette intervention en
compte n'avait pas simplement pour but
unique l'activation de l'article 38 on
ne me voit pas on fait un contre avant
de voter pour et ensuite on close les
débats je le dis c'est peu glorieux
chers collègues et votre volonté de
corseter les débats transforme nos
débats en pantomine la pièce était si
mauvaise que même les acteurs
l'aquitaient avant sa fin c'est ce que
je vais faire ce soir merci chers
collègues monsieur ozoulias
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues moi je
veux intervenir sur sur la limite d'âge
que vous proposez monsieur le monsieur
le ministre aujourd'hui l'âge moyen
d'entrer dans la carrière des métiers
d'enseignant et d'enseignants chercheurs
c'est 35 ans chez le ministre 35 ans
aujourd'hui c'est l'âge moyen pour
rentrer dans la carrière donc on peut on
peut comprendre que un fonctionnaire qui
devient chercheur il va commencer à
gagner suffisamment pour se racheter des
parts à partir de 35 ans donc si vous
mettez une limite qui a 30 ans vous vous
interdisez aux fonctionnaires de pouvoir
acheter des parts donc ça c'est un c'est
quelque chose d'importance qui se joue
derrière mes chers collègues et monsieur
le ministre c'est la fuite des cerveaux
jusqu'à présent les chercheurs étaient
mal payés mais ils avaient en récompense
une bonne retraite aujourd'hui ils vont
être mal payés ils auront une mauvaise
retraite ça veut dire qu'ils iront à
l'étranger l'objectif là aujourd'hui
pour nous c'est de les garder
et pour les garder il faut leur offrir
des bons salaires et une bonne retraite
monsieur le ministre est un enjeu
fondamental il s'agit ici de de la
nation française et de et de sa capacité
à développer des connaissances qui nous
permettront de d'affronter les enjeux
futurs je vous remercie monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur Cardon
oui c'était pour donner quelques
précisions parce que je comprends pas
trop l'argument du rapporteur étant
donné que si on rajoute 15 ans l'âge
moyen de on va dire pour rentrer en
jeunes actifs c'est 22-23 ans donc ça
fait 37 ans donc en fait ma proposition
est plus pertinente que la selle de
Monsieur donc je vous propose de voter
justement mon amendement jusqu'au bout
voilà
merci Madame présidente rossignol
si moi je vais vous dire que je ne
comprends même pas pourquoi il y a une
limite d'âge aussi proche de la fin des
études qui quel est le jeûne qui peut à
30 ans racheter ses trimestres de
cotisation
je voudrais te donner la réponse celui
dont les parents celui dont les parents
vont prendre en charge sera chaque
cotisation celui dont les parents vont à
la fois se préoccuper de sa retraite
évidemment il y a beaucoup de parents en
ce moment qui se préoccupe de la
question de la retraite mais surtout
celui dans les parents suffisamment
d'épargne pour pouvoir mettre sur la
table les quelques milliers d'euros qui
sont nécessaires à ça donc cette limite
d'âge elle sert à quoi à part à empêcher
le plus grand nombre d'étudiants issus
des classes populaires qui sont pas des
étudiants qui auront qui sont des pas
des fils d'un certain point de vue pas
des étudiants dont les parents qui ont
déjà souvent payé une grande partie des
études
cela ces étudiants là ils pourront
jamais racheter en fait le principe même
d'une limite d'âge n'est pas
compréhensible si ce n'est dans son
caractère dissuasif et pour faire faire
des économies donc je pense que
l'amendement de Monsieur Cardon qui est
celui qui se rapproche le plus de mon
propos me paraît que le meilleur merci
Monsieur Chassin
le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
donc je suis moi tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qui vient d'être dit notamment
Pierre ouzouillas parce que si vous
voulez à 30 ans souvent bon les
personnes qui ont fait des études
longues bien pense pas forcément tout de
suite je pense qu'il faudrait mettre un
délai afin que toutes ces personnes
puissent effectivement s'il le souhaite
faire des rachats merci chez nous
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je trouve que c'est des bases
sur la limite d'âge et est intéressant
juste et qu'à mon avis il concerne un
certain nombre de personnes moi je
pensais notamment au professeur qui
avant d'être titularisé ont été maître
auxiliaires et qui ont eu une période
pour acheter leur trimestre ou leurs
années et qui parfois n'avait pas
forcément au moment où c'était ouvert la
possibilité d'acheter ces
trimestres et et il est évident que
c'est cette possibilité devrait être
ouverte beaucoup plus longtemps parce
que au fond ça n'est que justice parce
qu'une fois que la période est fermée et
elle est quelquefois fermée parce que
les personnes ont des charges de famille
ou autre charge autour de moyens ça crée
une injustice de faite et donc c'est un
sujet qui me paraît indispensable à
regarder très près je vous remercie
merci Monsieur Gillet
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le rapporteur on est là dans un exemple
type où on est en train d'approfondir
véritablement le sujet et donc le débat
est en train de s'instaurer et les
éléments qui sont mis sur la table
tendent à démontrer que la proposition
de Monsieur Cardon et en représente
reprenant les éléments de monsieur nous
permettrait effectivement d'avancer
collectivement sur le sujet et de faire
une proposition qui pourrait tous nous
agréer donc monsieur le ministre je
pense qu'on nous pourrions aller vers le
mieux disant en la matière puisque de
toute évidence sur ces sujets là
l'engagement financier semble quand même
relatif et nous permettrait quand même
de satisfaire effectivement le plus mon
nombre et de démontrer que le débat
parlementaire de qualité nous permet
effectivement d'avoir des accords
intelligents je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre
merci monsieur le Président je souhaite
rassuré monsieur ozoulias puisque je
n'ai pas été soit passé explicite soit
passé complet dans mon premier propos je
dis que l'objectif est que le la
rédaction telle qu'elle est proposée
prévoit que le décret fixe un âge de
rachat qui soit au minimum à 30 ans nous
pensons qu'il est utile qu'il est utile
d'avoir une borne collective qui soit
lisible puisque aujourd'hui le système
est très peu utilisé par manque de
lisibilité c'est vrai pour les études
c'est vrai pour les stages que nous
verrons tout à l'heure et donc avoir une
borne publique connue à 30 ans que je
qualifierais de droit commun pour celles
et ceux qui ont duré d'études classiques
nous paraît utile la deuxième chose qui
nous paraît extrêmement utile c'est
malgré tout d'avoir une limite d'âge
pour une seule raison c'est que nous
sommes je l'ai dit tout à l'heure à
propos d'autres rachats de trimestres
pour les apprentis nous sommes par la
loi dans un système où le coût de
rashtag trimestre est actuel ce qui
signifie que plus on le rachète tard
plus il est cher et donc limiter dans
l'âge permet aussi d'avoir une borne et
une cible connue à un moment de la vie
où le trimestre est encore accessible et
après je termine mon propos pour le cas
que vous avez évoqué c'est au minimum 30
ans pour avoir une forme d'âge de droit
commun bien évidemment dans le cas que
vous avez cité de personnes qui font des
études extrêmement longues pour devenir
chercheur le fait que la formulation de
l'amendement dise au minimum 30 ans nous
permettra dans le décret et en fonction
des cursus d'adapter et ainsi de
permettre à ceux qui le souhaitent de
racheter dans des bonnes conditions mais
en précisant pour être tout à fait
transparent et complet avec vous que
plus ce sera tard du fait de la méthode
actuelle et moi ça sera favorable
financièrement mais c'est la loi et
c'est ainsi prévu pour toutes les
systèmes de rachat à l'exception de de
l'exception pardon pour la répétition
que nous avons faite pour les anciens
trimestres d'apprentissage
donc je vais mettre aux voix les quatre
amendements identiques
77 1914 2021 3404
avec deux avis favorables qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient
ils sont adoptés et donc ils font tomber
le 2986
mes chers collègues il est quasiment 8
heures je vais suspendre la séance elle
sera reprise à 21h30 pour la suite de
l'examen de ce texte la séance est
suspendue